Joe: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between KFC in the US and Italy.
This is "Food Wars."
New season, Italy. New host.
I want to introduce you to a familiar
Food Insider face: Claudia.
Let's start with the
Original Recipe chicken.
If you're buying just
the original chicken,
you can get a two-piece. One is huge.
We also have lots of bucket options,
but most of them combine
the Original Recipe,
wings, and tenders.
If you only want the original chicken,
the largest size we have
is a six-piece bucket.
Looks a bit scary.
The other bucket options
include a variety of chicken,
such as tenders and hot wings.
For example, if you
want to feed two people,
you can get the 10-piece bucket.
This contains four tenders
and six crispy tenders.
And if you want to feed four people,
you can get this big boy here.
This one is a 16-piece bucket
and contains four Original Recipe,
four tenders, four crispy
tenders, and four wings.
This is actually the
biggest thing on the menu.
Then in the US, KFC's chicken
comes in four portion sizes.
You can start off by getting
a one-piece à la carte,
then a two-piece with a combo,
a three-piece with a combo,
and a four-piece with a combo,
all of which come with
a side of your choice,
a biscuit, and a drink.
Then for the buckets,
we have an eight-piece,
the 12-piece,
and last but not least,
this luscious bucket,
16 pieces of chicken.
Dinner is served in America.
You can get those in
either original or crispy.
That makes our biggest bucket
166% bigger than Italy's.
I've actually never really had KFC before.
Chicken is not so popular in Italy,
especially fried chicken served like that.
So I'm really curious to try it and see.
Yeah, nice.
Not a lot of spices. It's
just, like, fried chicken,
which is what we were promised.
Let's see how one chicken drumstick weighs
compared to Italy.
Claudia: 64 grams.
Joe: 97 grams.
Is anyone surprised that the
chicken in the United States
is bigger than every other country
we've done this "Food Wars" with?
In Italy, we also have hot wings,
and they come in a five-piece
and in a 18-piece bucket.
This one is designed for three people.
18 wings in the US is definitely
for one person, not three.
I could have six wings
and then have a full meal.
So, they're advertised as hot wings.
I think to an Italian palate,
yeah, you could say these are spicy.
We also got wings here in the US.
Now, currently, at least the
KFC I went to here in Burbank
has one size of wings, the eight-piece.
Go ahead and take the bones out.
Crispy.
Heat I can notice that isn't overwhelming.
Perfectly fine.
Next are the fries.
In Italy, you can get three sizes:
a small, medium, and large.
In the US we got two sizes of fries:
the individual and the large.
Claudia: Let's weigh our biggest size.
[laughs] I never grow tired of that.
Is this the lowest we've gotten?
We've gone to the same KFC every time,
but apparently they
have fired that scooper
because he or she was being too generous.
In Italy, KFC offers drinks in two sizes:
a medium and a large.
Drinks in the US, you get
two fountain-drink sizes,
the regular and the large.
I will point out to you,
Claudia, and the rest of Italy,
that our regular, the smallest
drink you can get at a KFC,
is 591 milliliters,
which is much bigger than your large.
But if you really want
your thirst quenched,
you can get yourself the big boy. Guszh!
That is a half gallon, 64 fluid ounces,
or 1,892.7 milliliters
of beverage.
Claudia: Let's measure the
large one to see if that's true.
Joe: Supposed to be 887.
Let me just see if we can
get it up to 800. Whoa.
This is just 800.
The messes that this
show forces me to make.
If you are incredible at balancing
and you don't want a cap,
I guess this is OK
if you're just going to sit
at your table like [slurps].
Here's everything that you
can get at KFC in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything you'll
find at a KFC in the US
you won't find in Italy.
We have one exclusive chicken
option you can't get in Italy.
That is the extra-crispy.
This is probably close to what you get,
the Original Recipe.
And then you got the extra-crispy.
I mean, obviously, it's night and day.
Volume up on this one.
This is regular [crunching],
and of course the extra-crispy
[louder crunching].
If you're wondering, yes, way better,
way more flavorful. Mm!
We don't have extra-crispy
chicken here in Italy,
but if you order tenders,
you're going to get original and crispy.
It does look much crispier.
It also looks, it just
looks much sadder as well,
because it's literally flopping.
At least I can see the chicken.
I can see some meat in there.
This one is completely
hidden in the batter.
Like, it could be anything.
Another exclusive are the KFC nuggets.
You can get these in
varieties of five, eight,
12, and 36.
I went with the five-piece.
Now, Claudia, take a good look at this.
You in Italy have popcorn chicken.
Besides potential size differences,
I really don't know what else
is different about these.
In Italy we don't have nuggets,
but we have popcorn chicken.
We got the large, but it comes
also in small and medium.
Quietly sometime last year,
KFC just took popcorn
chicken off the menu,
and I'm pretty bummed about that.
I mean, I like the nuggets,
but the popcorn chicken, man.
It's just something because
they're a lot smaller,
and then the chicken-to-skin ratio
is more in favor of the skin,
so you get a lot of that
savory skin in there.
RIP, popcorn chicken.
You're very lucky, Claudia.
You are very lucky.
Were you guys the guinea pigs for this,
or are we the guinea pigs for
a new recipe or something?
I think I prefer a whole piece.
I think bingeing on
little bits of chicken,
it's so un-Italian
that I'm not sure that I'll
be getting used to that.
Snacking on little bits of fried chicken
while in a convenient to-go box
while driving or walking around
is so American, and I love it.
I gotta try these.
This is what America's all about.
Let's move on to the chicken sandwiches.
In Italy, we have the Zinger.
This is supposed to be Italy's
version of the spicy chicken
that you guys have in the US.
I don't know, Joe, how does
that look like? Similar?
Yes, Claudia, your Zinger sandwich
looks a little bit like
our spicy chicken sandwich.
Here's ours, and we only
have pickles on ours,
so no lettuce and tomato.
But after I took a bite,
you can see there's, like, some red here,
so that's supposed to be the spice.
There's the tiniest, tiniest,
tiniest spice, to be honest.
Then, moving on, we have
this tiny little thing,
the Krunky.
Crunchy or Krunky.
This one here is on the value menu,
so it's a cheaper option.
And then we've got the Colonel,
named after Colonel Sanders.
We don't really have colonels here.
I think we do, but we
keep them for the army.
I don't think they've ever
opened a chicken restaurant.
Then we got the Double Colonel.
Does that mean that another person joined?
Then we have the Kentucky
chicken and bacon.
I have to say, this is the biggest bacon
that I've seen in
Italian fast-food chains.
This to me feels quite, quite fake.
You can also get this one in a double.
And then we have the chicken grilled.
So much sauce. Sad, sad
lettuce hanging off mayo.
You can also get the double crispy,
which is two chicken tenders in a bun.
Here are sandwiches you can get in the US
you can't get in Italy,
starting down here.
The classic Chicken Little.
I don't know, it's just a
tender in between two buns.
Here's what I would do: I would go to KFC,
I'd stand in line, I'd order
my meal and get one of these,
and then demand they give me this
while I wait for the rest of my food.
It's nothing. It's nothing.
It's like an appetizer.
And then, of course, just
the regular chicken sandwich.
I have said on record several times
that I think KFC might have the best
fast-food chicken sandwich in America.
There's also apparently an
ultimate barbecue fried chicken sandwich.
That was new. I think it came and went.
As an Italian, I'm not so
big on chicken burgers.
I think the idea of
having chicken in a burger
doesn't really resonate so well with us.
So it almost hurts my eyes.
There's just too much brown in it.
Like, I want to see more color.
Yeah, that's absolutely not the case here.
As you can see, our chicken is deep-fried
and covered in a mayo-y sauce.
We're eating chicken
all the time in America.
Yeah, we eat a lot of beef,
but we also eat a lot of chicken,
and it is in no way diet
food here. Not at all.
We also used to have twisted
wraps here at KFC in Italy,
but suddenly they're
not on the menu anymore.
They're still worth mentioning, though,
because of the hilarious
advertising campaign.
When KFC launched them in Italy,
they actually designed
Italian leather handbags
supposed to hold your Twisters,
which is a bit of a knockoff
to the Fendi Baguette bag.
All right, we might not have
Italian bags for our wraps,
but we do have KFC Crocs.
Look how cool those look.
[crickets]
We do have a couple wrap options.
You can only get them
through the KFC application,
which is not how I ordered.
Anyway, you can get the classic
one with a crispy tender.
There's also a spicy one
that I assume is spicier.
And, apparently, you can
get two of them for $5,
which is a pretty good
deal. But I didn't get that.
Here's a few hilarious things
you can't get in Italy.
Over here's the Famous Bowl.
Yes, Claudia, I know you're
dying to know all about this,
so I will tell you now.
It is nuggets, mashed
potatoes, gravy, corn,
cheese, all in one convenient tub.
So, this would be, I guess,
what's considered a bite.
It's really heavy.
It's gotta be 90% mashed potato.
It's a lot.
Another American exclusive
is this, a chicken pot pie.
Look at the size of this thing.
I think this would just
profoundly confuse every Italian.
Here's the thing about the
mashed potatoes and gravy.
You have to get them together.
Having them separately
seems very strange to me.
It is a classic US side dish,
especially with things like fried chicken.
Apparently when Colonel
Sanders sold the business,
he compared the mashed
potatoes in a Manhattan store
to "wallpaper paste" topped with "sludge."
But that was back in the '70s,
so hopefully they've
made some improvements.
I'd say that they have.
I mean, I know, like, those
mashed potatoes look so dry.
I understand you want to put
some sort of liquid on them.
I'd just not have any of it.
But for once,
the potatoes don't look
radioactively yellow,
so that should be a good sign.
We happen to have some Italian-style
sides here on the menu,
although I have no idea who
called this Italian style,
because none of these
really look Italian to me.
We have cheese puffs.
To me, these look like fried Babybels.
That's the only cheese that I can think of
that has this shape.
I think it's some kind of mozzarella.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah, we have bread.
Just, like funny bread.
It looks very dry, just by looking at it.
And then we have corn on the cob.
The US has off the cob.
This is not Italian.
I've never seen an Italian
person having corn on the cob.
In Italy, we also have four salads,
but we were not able to get them today.
Those are grilled chicken,
crispy chicken, and original chicken,
which, we don't know how that
differs from the crispy one,
and a veggie salad.
Right, Claudia, look at that.
Look at that mac and cheese.
It's American mac and cheese.
I mean, I don't really have
thoughts about mac and cheese,
because to me that's just not Italian.
We just sort of gave up on it and be like,
"You want it? It's yours."
Yeah, I get it. Like, bright yellow.
But Claudia, what you can't tell
is how good this tastes.
Other US sides you can get here: coleslaw.
Claudia was talking about corn on the cob.
We got corn off the cob, aka sweet corn.
I'm just thinking, in terms
of the American experience,
I don't want to be all,
like, doing this at my desk
when I get KFC for lunch, you know?
I just want to eat it and get going, so.
Another thing we have here, biscuits.
And I feel like you get these
with these types of meals
because it's good at sopping up things,
like good at sopping up the gravy.
On their own, they're
just so ... [thudding].
I want to see if I can eat
one without any liquid,
like, how long it takes me
to eat a dry one. Ready?
This is how dry these
are. Ready? Time me. Go.
Only halfway through!
Ugh, it hurts to talk.
Time.
Yeah, not my favorite.
Another exclusive you
can get here in the US
is a piece of à la carte chicken.
I feel like if you went into
a KFC in Italy and was like,
"I just want one drumstick,"
they'd give it to you.
I don't think they'd
really push back on it.
But our menu specifically has,
you get an individual piece of chicken.
You can get a drumstick,
a thigh, or a breast.
You get chicken in this hand,
Famous Bowl in this hand,
and walk right into traffic.
Sauce talk, let's go.
Discorso di la salsa.
In Italy, we have some exclusive sauces,
starting from the original.
I know you guys in the
US have the KFC sauce.
Does this look similar?
I think if I were making sauces,
I would've just continued,
you know, trialing others after this one.
Yeah, it's, like, a
mayo-y barbecue ketchup.
And then we have the smoky barbecue sauce.
And then we have the sweet imperial sauce.
That's a sweet and sour sauce.
Very lemony, but fresh.
Yeah, it's a nice one. I like this.
Then move on to the 2 hot 4 U.
Jelly-like.
It's not too hot for you,
it's just too bad for me.
Moving on, we also have garlic sauce.
I know you guys associate Italy
and Italian cuisine with garlic.
Please stop doing that.
We don't really like it.
Then we have a fresh pepper one.
This one apparently contains cheese.
Tastes like not much, to be honest.
We also have creamy curry.
Finally, we couldn't
get the only olive oil,
but we do have olive oil and white vinegar
and olive oil and balsamic vinegar.
I don't know if you want to
consider olive oil a sauce.
I have mixed feeling about it,
because that's definitely more dressing.
Are you curious to see how
chicken olive oil tastes like?
Let's try it.
Olive oil and balsamic vinegar. Let's see.
Kind of brought it back
to life a little bit,
because it had cooled down.
Yeah, I should do this
more often, actually.
It tastes less fried for some reason.
Because I always associate olive oil
with, like, grilled chicken.
So if you want to trick
your mind into thinking
that you're eating grilled
chicken and not fried,
maybe all you have to do is
pour some olive oil on it.
Joe: Honey mustard.
Honey barbecue.
That's good. Buffalo ranch.
If you are unaware, we have a sauce here
that usually is on wings
called the Buffalo sauce.
It's a vinegary hot sauce
that is a little north of mild.
And the reason that
Buffalo ranch is a thing
is because when you eat Buffalo
wings and they're spicy,
you dip the wings in ranch, a
second sauce, to cool it down.
So we as Americans are used
to pairing Buffalo sauce on the wings
with ranch dressing.
So they were like, let's
just put it in one,
because God forbid we have two sauces.
But if you want to have
just regular ranch,
everyone on the internet
come at me, all right?
Ranch is just OK. It all tastes the same.
Also we have a hot sauce.
A honey sauce.
We have a lot of dessert
options here in Italy.
Most of them are just ice cream.
We start from a plain ice cream cone.
Then you can get sundaes.
They come plain, caramel flavor,
Nutella, strawberry, and chocolate.
And then we have these, the Kream Balls.
They come with Nutella flavor, caramel,
strawberry, and chocolate.
They're kind of similar to a sundae,
but they have this crunchy bottom.
And apparently the caramel one
is supposed to have lots of layers.
This is the caramel one.
But I'm not sure we can
judge the number of layers,
because it has absolutely melted.
So, we got a Nutella Kream
Ball and a caramel one.
You know those backpacks for cats?
I think it's the same thing here.
I'm curious about the crunchy bottom.
Oh, yeah, that is crunchy.
Actually it reminds me a little bit of
the Algida, the Cornetto.
It may have another name in the US.
And they have that
crunchy bit at the bottom.
I mean, for us Italian, Nutella
is like the OG chocolate.
Before chocolate always comes Nutella,
just no questions asked.
It's always been like this.
And before cream as well.
The only exclusive dessert
option we have in America
is this: a chocolate cake.
And it just occurred to me,
I've actually never had this cake.
Let's see how we did.
Perfect.
Cooked beautifully.
It's got the right amount
of bounce, isn't dried out.
And now we taste it.
Exquisite.
You keep baking like that,
you can win this competition.
I started off as Gordon Ramsay.
Every impression I do of
anyone is just kind of that.
This is actually pretty good.
Yeah, they had those
balls, those Kream Balls,
which is kind of a weird thing to call it.
No, I don't want any of those.
I get it. I like dessert
just as much as the next guy.
But KFC, I want to load
up on fried chicken.
I want to load up on mac and cheese.
I want to load up on mashed potatoes.
I want to load up on corn.
If only someone could put
it all in one bowl for me.
Dessert? No, I want to eat fried chicken
until I'm about to burst,
and then I'm out. So.
The exclusive drinks in Italy are
7Up, Lipton iced tea, and beer.
Fountain drinks you can get in the US.
We do have a bunch of exclusives.
I didn't get every single one, relax.
All right, starting down here.
Sweet tea.
Oh, yeah, their lemonade.
It's really good. It's addictive.
And our lemonade is not
carbonated, it's still.
Mountain Dew, it's fantastic.
And the reason I saved this one for last,
it's something you can get
exclusively at the KFC in the US,
it's Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning.
It's so good. Like, you
just know it's super sweet,
and super chemically, but I love it.
Other drinks you can get at
a US KFC that we did not get
was Starry and blackberry lemonade,
which is currently unavailable.
Which country's getting
a better deal on its KFC?
Let's compare a few
menu items to find out.
Looking at the chicken
sandwich combo meal,
which comes with a side
and a medium drink,
this whole thing in Los
Angeles would cost you $10.99.
Note, if you got each item
individually, added up,
it would be $12.77.
In Italy, you can also get a similar meal
that is called a Zinger meal,
and that includes a sandwich,
a side of choice, and a drink.
This will cost you 10 euros and 40 cents.
At the time of recording,
that is equal to $11.52.
So that is 5% more
expensive than the US meal.
If you order these items individually,
that will cost you 13 euros and 60 cents,
and that's about $15.06.
We also took a look at
KFC's most expensive items.
In Italy, the most
expensive item on the menu
is the 16-piece bucket.
This one costs 42 euros 90 cents,
which is about $47.51.
This is supposed to feed four people
for $11.87 per person.
The most expensive item on the US menu
is the 16-piece chicken meal,
which includes 16 pieces of chicken,
original or crispy,
four large sides, eight biscuits,
and it costs you $52.99.
Now, this is meant to feed
seven to eight people.
Sure.
And it costs roughly $6.62 per person,
which is 44% cheaper than
Italy's per-person cost.
Italy KFC puts a lot of effort
into its meals and special offers
so they can be a better
value for the money.
Personally, in Italy, we're not
really used to having meals.
We are very accustomed to
just having a big main course.
That to me still feels a
bit of an American thing.
But this is American food,
so I guess we are using
their customs as well.
If you're operating under the assumption
that this is for seven people,
it's a pretty good deal.
But you and I both know
this ain't for seven people.
We want to see if there
are any similarities
in the nutrition of
KFC for both countries.
Now, this is our chicken sandwich,
and it has 650 calories.
And if you'll notice,
there's a lot of salt
and fat in this sandwich,
over half your daily recommended intake.
KFC Italy doesn't disclose their calories
on their website.
Actually, I think disclosing
nutritional information,
like calories and everything,
I find that quite an American thing.
That doesn't mean it's good or bad.
It's just like, we don't really
tend to count calories in things.
Every "Food Wars" we've
done, all the nutrition info,
all the ingredients info, in the US,
you can get it, no problem.
Other countries, they don't provide it.
Let's take a look at some ingredients
that KFC uses here in Italy.
Here are all the
ingredients for the fries.
Nine is a lot.
Potatoes and frying oil, how about two?
Two ingredients, and a bit
of salt, and one chemical.
Let's just use one, you
know, if we have to.
And here are all the ingredients
of the fries in the US.
33 ingredients.
That's 24 more than the
ingredients in Italy's fries.
That's nuts.
Claudia: Nine ingredients for this thing,
and it doesn't even hold its shape.
I would expect it to be perfect.
There's a lot of flavors
and colorings that we use,
like paprika, turmeric,
and annatto extract color,
which is funny we put that into the fries,
but when making this, KFC also
uses bleached white flour,
which removes all the color,
so it seems kind of counterproductive.
Like, they're taking all the color out
with the bleached flour, right?
And they're putting all
those chemicals back in
to make them look like fries.
I don't know why we do that either.
So, let's have a look at the ingredients
for a chicken drumstick.
Italy's chicken uses a
lot of flavor enhancers,
gums, and stabilizers.
For example, xanthan gum and guar gum.
They're used in meat products
to keep the chicken tender
during the cooking process.
These gums are also used for chicken
that has a batter around
it, so that when it's fried,
it absorbs less oil.
As I said before, Italians
don't really look at ingredients
or nutritional value of things.
And that is why I think there is
a lot of work done beforehand for us
in order to make the food
as simple as possible,
so that if you do look at the ingredients,
you are not so shocked by it.
And here are the ingredients
of the chicken in the US.
Surprisingly smaller than Italy's list,
although the US has not noted
what oil they use for frying,
like Italy has.
So it would probably add
a few more ingredients.
Now, KFC actually uses pressure frying
instead of deep frying,
like the other chains,
as it allows for faster cooking time
and always keeps the meat moister,
as less steam evaporates.
Let's take a closer look
at a few ingredients
that some of us may not recognize.
OK, first up, sodium phosphate.
Now, it helps stabilize the pH of the food
to keep them together.
But it's also popular
over-the-counter medicine
for bowel movements.
So don't be surprised if eating KFC
makes you rush to the bathroom.
Next up, monosodium glutamate,
flavor enhancer commonly added
to soups and processed meats.
Ugh. We're putting these
names on-screen, right?
Ah, this word looks like this
and is probably pronounced
dime-thigh-polo-sigh-lexane.
Computer: Dimethylpolysiloxane.
It's an antifoaming agent
derived from silicone,
usually added to oils,
jams, and canned vegetables.
Disodium dihydrogen pyrophosphate.
This should be a contest. Anyway. OK.
Prevents potatoes in the
fries from turning brown
due to oxidization,
which is natural for most
fruits and vegetables.
And just to add that all these ingredients
have been approved by health professionals
and there are no safety concerns,
as long as they're eaten
in lower quantities,
which, in general, is good
advice for eating fast food.
Chickens in the US are free of
added hormones and steroids.
However, KFC does not disclose much else
about how the chicken is prepared,
nor how much chicken is used per item.
As of 2019, Yum Brands,
the parent company of KFC,
stopped purchasing chicken
raised using antibiotics.
So I guess they're heading
in the right direction.
KFC opened their first outlet in the '70s
in Naples for some reason.
And then that didn't work
out, and they closed.
And then they came back to Italy in 2014.
The objective was to open
100 branches in four years.
They're not quite there yet.
As of 2022, the stats say
that they've opened 68
branches here in Italy.
Although it's been here since 2014,
it does still feel pretty new.
Like, Italians are not so big on chicken,
especially grilled chicken.
It does still feel like
a very foreign idea.
KFC is so popular in the US,
maybe the most popular chicken chain,
fried-chicken chain at least.
I think it's the
fried-chicken chain to beat in the US.
There's other chicken places
that do chicken sandwiches,
chicken burgers. But as
far as chicken on the bone,
I don't know who's even
competing with KFC.
Ah, I guess there's Popeyes.
Oh, yeah, Popeyes.
No, I think KFC is way
more popular than Popeyes.
I didn't say it's better.
If a KFC opens in a new town,
for example, in my hometown
they opened last year,
there are huge lines.
There are a lot of people
that want to try it
because it's really the idea
of the American fast-food
chain that's arriving.
So it's exciting. It's different.
Again, it's one of those
things that I think
you do try it because of the hype.
KFC adaptability is
weird. A couple years ago,
there used to be a lot
more stuff on the menu.
And now there's a lot less.
So their adaptability is
less about making stuff
that kind of caters to people's tastes,
and more like, "No
one's getting the wings,
let's just do the nuggets.
Let's take all this stuff off the menu,
let's pare it down, go,
go, go," for efficiency,
and probably because it's
cheaper to have less ingredients.
So they've adapted to, I don't know,
shifts in the market or
people's interest in KFC.
They really don't deviate
too far, dish-wise,
from, like, a fried chicken
or a chicken in a bun.
KFC is actually the chain that has made
the least effort to Italianize the menu.
I don't know. Actually, weirdly,
I think that for this it works,
because the idea of eating fried chicken
is so foreign to us that I
don't know how you would,
how would you make that Italian?
You'd maybe put some, like,
fried courgette flowers with the chicken?
I don't know.
For me to even think about
a similar Italian thing,
that, weirdly, I think this
may be working the way it is.
So we'll see when they
will reach 100 branches.
Maybe sooner than we think.
Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and Italy.
This is "Food Wars."
Drinks at McDonald's in
Italy come in three sizes,
250 milliliters,
400 milliliters,
and 500 milliliters.
We're now going to measure
a 500-ml Coke to see if that's true.
Oh, oh.
I think we're surpassing that.
It's just right below the 600 mark,
but almost there.
So quite generous.
Drinks in the US also come in four sizes.
The extra small, which is 355 milliliters,
or 12 fluid ounces.
The small, 474 milliliters,
or 16 fluid ounces.
And the medium, 621
milliliters, or 21 fluid ounces.
And the large, 946 milliliters,
or 32 fluid ounces.
Since we were the ones that
filled this up at the restaurant
and I don't think we got it all full up,
I'm going to go ahead and fill this
what I think is reasonable.
I can't do to the top
because the cap is recessed.
OK. 32? Surely you jest.
But there's the 32 line. Not even close.
It's closer to 24 than it is 32.
So, fries in Italy come in three sizes.
The regular, which is
technically the small,
medium, and large.
Here in America, our
fries come in four sizes.
The kids, which comes in the Happy Meal.
Look at this little guy.
Little guy!
The small, the medium, and the large.
All the "Food Wars" heads watching
know that in the China episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 175 grams.
In the Japan episode,
our large McDonald's fry was 190 grams.
So clearly there's some
difference in grammage
depending on, I don't know,
the McDonald's we go to,
the scooper, who knows?
So we're going to weigh
our large right now.
Ready? Fantastic.
Eh, let's go 185.
Not a bad scoop. We got
a good scooper this time.
Seems pretty small, actually.
What about McNuggets?
In Italy you can get a bag of four,
a box of six pieces,
nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
Claudia, in the US,
our McNuggets are
available in these sizes:
the four-piece, the
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
which you also have, but we go
up one more here in America.
Our largest size, the 40-piece.
Now, if my calculations are correct,
this is double your largest size.
The iconic Big Mac.
Both countries have it,
but we're going to compare
ours to Italy's by weighing it.
226 grams for a US Big Mac.
And here is an Italian Big Mac,
or Il Big Mac, as is written here,
and we're going to weigh it now.
209 grams.
Here are all the items on
the McDonald's Italy menu
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the McDonald's
menu items from the US
you won't find in Italy.
Get a good look, Claudia.
Let's start from the burgers.
We have a bunch of Italian burgers
that you won't get in the US.
The first one we got here
is a chicken Big Mac.
Oh, right. Just destroyed chicken Big Mac.
Has that been inverted?
Is that supposed to look like this?
The cheese helps a little
bit. Sauce as well.
Moving on, we have a bacon Big Mac.
Yeah, there's two strips of bacon,
but they're not quite
big, so it does look like
maybe it's just one
that's been cut in half.
We got a crispy McBacon,
which is like cheeseburger,
double patty, and some bacon
again, a bit on the side.
It's funny actually because growing up,
I thought that the crispy McBacon
was the iconic McDonald's item,
and it's weird that it is
actually an Italian exclusive.
Here are all the burgers in the US
that you can't get in Italy.
Starting down here, the
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
It really is just a cheeseburger
that is a quarter pound of meat.
It's a great go-to burger.
Meat, cheese, onions,
pickles, ketchup, and mustard.
And if you want more meat,
you can get the double Quarter Pounder.
Correct. Not the half pounder,
the double Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Two patties, more meat, more cheese.
Fantastic sandwich.
And then we've got the first one
of the My Selection range,
which is a range that was
designed with Joe Bastianich.
He's an American TV personality and chef.
This one is speck and Asiago,
so yeah, very traditional.
Speck is a type of cured
meat. It's like a smoked ham.
Yeah, it's a smoked ham
from the north of Italy.
It's actually very, very nice,
just very salty with that smoky flavor.
It's one of my favorites.
And then we have Asiago,
which is a cheese made
pretty much in the same area.
There's also mayo and zucchini in there.
A bit dry, I think.
You do taste the cold cut, the speck.
Just brings that saltiness, smokiness.
Very nice, and the cheese
also is quite good.
Yeah, actually I don't
know if you've noticed,
but it is much bigger than the others.
You can even take, like, bacon Big Mac.
Even though it's supposed
to have two patties,
it is much bigger.
And then we have another
My Selection burger.
This one is called My BBQ.
This one has got barbecue sauce,
yes, I can see it,
Gouda cheese, and bacon,
and it's all topped off
with some balsamic vinegar.
It does still have the
same sort of fancy patty
that we had before.
Right, and after these very
nice and fancy burgers,
we have a gluten-free burger.
Oh. [record scratching]
Wait, why does it come in a bag?
Ooh. Yeah. Very -- ooh.
Yeah, not excited about this.
Just, I don't like the bread.
I'm sure you can find
better gluten-free bread.
There are so many around.
And if you want vegetables on your burger
for some strange reason,
you can get the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe,
with lettuce and tomato and mayo.
Oh, did you see that squirt coming out?
Hit, like, a pocket of
mayonnaise on that one.
That's kind of weird.
It tastes great.
And if you just want to
go all in on the meat,
you can get a double
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Look at this.
Right?
It's really good. Enough said.
And, surprise, another thing on our menu
you guys don't have: the McDouble.
McDonald's has a double cheeseburger,
which is double the
meat, double the cheese,
but also there's a McDouble on the menu.
What's the difference, you ask?
Well, McDouble only has
one slice of cheese.
As you can see from here, on top,
you got ketchup, mustard,
and pickles, no cheese.
The cheese is in between here.
I get it. Times are tough in this economy,
but get the extra slice
of cheese, guys. Come on.
I mean, we're not robots here.
We gotta have some pleasure in our lives,
and I think you should get
that extra slice of cheese.
Absorb the cost of it.
It's perfectly fine.
You're doing great. Come on!
Next one is another one
of those My Selection.
It's a chicken, avocado, and bacon burger.
Hm, it's got a different bun, this one.
Ooh, fancy.
All right, yeah, avocado is there.
There's, like, cabbage.
Mm, bit less excited about that.
And this one has
caciocavallo Silano cheese.
I don't know. We can call this --
you know sauce talk. The cheese talk.
Caciocavallo comes from the
same family of mozzarella.
They're called pasta filata cheeses,
and it's just basically the
way that you make cheese,
when you split the milk
into curds and whey.
It's made in a different way.
And you could say that caciocavallo
is like an aged mozzarella.
So it's a very versatile cheese
that I think is not
very well known abroad.
So, yeah, thank you, McDonald's,
for making that a thing
on your menu so everybody
can know about it.
So, here's the cheese that we
were talking about. [laughs]
It's just always a shame.
It's been put there with,
like, avocado and this cabbage.
Next one, we've got
double chicken barbecue.
After seeing all these big
ones, they do look quite small.
And then we have a chicken burger.
This one is different from a McChicken
because it has Caesar
sauce and no lettuce.
I think this is glue.
It looks like -- there is a type of glue
that looks exactly like that.
We also thought it'd be
fun to compare Happy Meals.
Here's the US one.
Open up this box, take a look around.
I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon.
This one comes with kid fries,
nuggets, which, we got a six-piece,
and this is their Pokémon toy.
So, they get the six-piece.
It's funny, like, a six-piece still seems
kind of like a lot for a kid.
Pokémon-themed toys
coming at you these days.
What is this?
OK, so we got Pikachu.
Does this have any value?
Because there's rare ones.
There's ones that have
a lot of value to them.
But not the ones at McDonald's, right?
Cyclizar? Any value?
We got Tandemaus.
Yeah.
And, of course, Sandaconda.
I'll go look on eBay after this
and see if these are worth anything.
Culturally, I have no idea what this is.
I don't know what -- this is a thing?
No, I have no idea who.
I don't remember any of those names.
Charlizard?
Cylizard?
Is this Cylizard?
Charmagarg.
OK.
In a Happy Meal in Italy,
you can find four items.
Obviously there is a drink,
then there is a main course
that could be either
nuggets [or] a hamburger.
And exclusive to Italy is a chicken burger
and a McToast, which is what we got today.
We're going to see that in a moment.
Then there is a side.
It can either be fries or baby carrots.
And a dessert.
This can be either fresh fruit, Actimel,
which is technically a drink
but it's a dessert here,
and Parmesan.
Here's our McToast. Nice.
The surprise of the day.
Yeah, they're just doing some
Hot Wheels collaboration.
So let's have a look at what is it.
I don't know, do you think
I can find a Vespa in here?
Oh, cute little skateboard,
pink one.
Nyoom.
We also have one exclusive
wrap option here in Italy.
It's a McWrap with crisp chicken breast
and Parmesan, or Parmigiano-Reggiano.
It's made in collaboration
with Giallozafferano,
which is the No. 1
recipe website in Italy.
To be honest, I think
they could have come up
with a better recipe, maybe, for the wrap.
The wrap does look very
sad, just the actual bread.
Chicken looks OK.
Italy clearly has plenty of exclusive
chicken-sandwich options, but
we have a few of our own here,
namely the McCrispy and the spicy McCrispy
and a deluxe version of each sandwich.
Let's take a look.
It looks closer to a chicken sandwich
you would find at a Chick-fil-A,
and then now Burger King has
the chicken king, I think?
McDonald's did all the
research that they do
to release this, the McCrispy sandwich.
Now, as you can tell,
it's just pickles on here.
A crispier, more natural-looking
piece of fried chicken,
and no sauce. Does it
always have no sauce?
I don't like that. I don't like
a place that gives you food
and, like, assembly requirements.
For the most part, I
should get the sandwich
the way it's supposed to be.
So this put your own sauce in it,
it's like, no, you put it on.
Here's the deluxe of it.
Yay, it has mayo. Whoa.
This to me is like,
yeah, do this every time.
This should just be the
sandwich. I don't ...
If you're like me and
you want to spice it up,
ah,
they have the spicy -- oh, come on.
There's spicy sauce on here somewhere.
Then, of course, they
got the spicy deluxe,
which of course has spicy sauce
and all those veggies in there.
So, yeah. McDonald's, still a contender
in the chicken-sandwich game, I feel.
Now we're on to the exclusive
sides here in Italy.
The first one that we got is cheesy fries.
The same fry, just with a
bit more bacon we got here.
Yeah, cheddar and bacon.
This is, like, I don't know,
a very sad Italian take on poutine.
On the menu next for sides,
we've got panzerotti.
So, actually very excited
about these because,
ooh,
panzerotti are from my hometown,
Bari, in the south of Italy.
The main difference is
that usually panzerotti,
the traditional ones, they are this big.
They're usually pretty wide.
It's, like, a main meal.
Panzerotti normally, they
have, tomatoes and mozzarella
is the most common filling,
but in Bari, again,
where they are from, you can
get them with ground beef,
mozzarella, and cooked ham.
These are actually my favorites.
I used to go and get them after school.
That's just, they are the perfect snack.
Quite good, actually.
Filling is OK, but I
think a real panzerotto,
when you bite into it,
basically all the filling
should almost come out.
It should, like, pop.
Like, the first reaction
when you eat a panzerotti,
this is like,
and then you sort of put your hand here
and just avoid a complete mess.
This brings us to the next snack,
which is Parmigiano-Reggiano, or Parmesan.
This is one of the most
counterfeit cheeses
in the world, so.
In Italy but also in Europe,
because of this whole protection thing,
anything that's called even
Parmesan, not the real name,
Parmigiano-Reggiano, is
in fact the real thing,
so at least we are safe on that side.
Having said that, I think
most of the Parmesan,
Parmigiano that you will
find around in supermarkets,
it's been aged for the bare minimum,
which is 12 months.
So it is good, it is the real thing,
but if you can choose,
just have something that's
been aged for a bit longer.
I think in Italy we do eat a lot of cheese
as a snack as it is, and I
do have definitely memories
of me coming back from school
and then just in the afternoon grabbing
some cheese off the fridge
and having a couple of slices
or even more than that.
I think my mom still does that,
so, sorry for exposing you, Mom.
Love it.
Over here we got another exclusive.
There are actually three
salads on the menu.
One is just a plain salad,
one is a salad with tomatoes,
and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan.
We could also select a dressing,
and we added olive oil.
You could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar
or just vinegar.
We actually have no
exclusive sides in the US.
Every side option on our menu
can also be found in Italy.
I will say, though, I love that they have
a stick of cheese as a side,
kind of like a palate cleanser.
I would love that.
I would love to snack on cheese.
I love snacking on cheese.
We should have more cheese,
is what I'm trying to say.
We can bring it back with the sauces.
It's time for sauce talk, Italy edition.
La la la sauce talk!
That had to offend somebody.
Sauce talk.
We have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States,
including spicy Buffalo,
and then we have ranch, honey
mustard, sweet 'n' sour.
Now, I have two because one
is from the movie "Loki," apparently.
And of course you just get honey.
Of all these, I'd probably
go sweet 'n' sour,
but barbecue, which they
do have, is my favorite.
We have one exclusive sauce in Italy,
which is spicy mustard sauce.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is a bit spicy.
Not so much, though.
Doesn't numb your tongue.
I think actually it has a sweet
aftertaste for some reason.
For the early risers,
there are plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's,
and they're all savory.
Now, first thing I'm going to
talk about are the biscuits.
I'm not the person to
describe American biscuits
to the rest of the world.
They should have hired a poet.
This is the bacon, egg,
and cheese biscuit,
but you can get a biscuit version
of any meat or cheese
combination that you want.
In the middle here, though,
Italy, Claudia, everyone,
look at what I'm about to show you.
You know what pancakes are.
You know what syrup is.
You obviously know what
breakfast sandwiches are.
This right here is a McGriddle,
and they replaced the buns with this.
These bun pancakes.
This is a pancake, Italy. A pancake.
These, here. And they somehow
injected syrup in them,
so it's not like syrup like a sauce,
it's just, like, already syrup somehow,
and it is savory and
sweet at the same time.
It is so delicious.
It's a McGriddle. It's
fantastic. I love these.
This is a bacon, egg,
and cheese McGriddle,
but once again, you can get
it in any various sausage,
egg, and/or cheese
combination that you want.
McGriddles. Check 'em out.
I am the McGriddle No. 1 fan over here.
And the OG breakfast sandwich,
this is the egg McMuffin.
They got the Big Breakfast
with or without hotcakes.
I went with hotcakes.
You got eggs, bacon,
pancakes, English muffin,
this thing's fantastic.
And if you want to just
get hotcakes and sausage,
you can also do that.
And each order of pancakes
comes with our hotcakes syrup.
I think an unsung hero of the
McDonald's breakfast menu,
been a fan of this for years,
it is the sausage breakfast burrito.
Now, let's be honest.
Italy, in case you're wondering,
this in no way represents
an actual burrito.
I want to make that perfectly clear.
I would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito,
breakfast or otherwise,
but it's its own thing, and
I think it is fantastic.
It is in a flour tortilla.
Scrambled eggs, sausage, yes, I know,
peppers, cheese, and the secret weapon
is this, their Mexican-style salsa.
Again, there is nothing
authentically Mexican about this,
but it tastes great.
This was a go-to for years.
I could put away about four of these.
McDonald's also does offer oatmeal,
specifically fruit and maple oatmeal.
Moving on.
The Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items.
We've got ... [laughs]
That's super sad.
We got scrambled eggs with
bacon and a muffin and bread,
which does look more like a muffin.
And then we have a McMuffin
with bacon and egg.
Yeah, Italians don't really
have savory breakfast.
It's definitely a habit.
Like, you just associate
breakfast with sweet items.
All right, US also has their
own exclusive McCafé items.
Where'd they go?
The McDonald'ses near our studio
did not have the McCafé food items.
McDonald's in Italy has
really made an effort
with the McCafé menu items,
and there are really a lot
of items on the menu here.
So let's start from the croissants.
We've got quite a few on the menu.
I think this one here,
because you can see a little bit of brown,
this is the cocoa one with sourdough.
Pretty safe to eat.
This is the plain one.
Does look more like a
French-style croissant.
Nice layers in there as well, some air.
Over here, it's quite hard to tell,
but there is a subtle,
subtle layer of jam.
This is berries and cereal.
So, the dough, it's a little bit stiffer,
and, yeah, does smell a little bit
more like cereals.
Same amount of jam as in the others.
Not very generous, actually.
I think this one is the
last one that we got,
so it's the custard.
This looks like we have
a bit more in there.
Obviously, it's hard to tell
because the custard is the
same color as the dough,
has kind of turned the dough yellow.
Nice. Lots of lemon in there.
Another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid.
This is quite a typical
thing as well in Italy.
Like, you do get these kind of pastries.
You can get them also savory
in different regions of Italy.
Let's see if they were
generous with the cream here.
Mm, yeah, I'll say so.
I prefer this cream.
In Italy, you can also get some cakes.
We have tiramisu, which is,
yeah, traditional Italian thing,
but not a breakfast item.
Like, I wouldn't really have
breakfast with tiramisu.
I know you guys want to hear
the opinion of an Italian,
so we're going to try this
tiramisu and see if it's proper.
Yes, quite good, actually.
We do have other cakes as well.
We have this one, which is
torta della nonna in Italian,
and that literally translates to
"grandma's cake" in English.
This one has lemon custard and pine nuts.
I think it's a bit of a joke
that this is actually
called grandma's cake
just because every Italian grandma
that's good in the kitchen
will be able to make something,
like, 100 times better than this.
We've got a strawberry cheesecake.
Let's move on to this
three-layer chocolate cake.
It's an absolute beast.
It's a bit too much.
I wouldn't have this for breakfast.
And then we have a few more items here
at the McCafé in Italy.
We have a marshmallow doughnut,
which looks like the most artificial thing
I've ever seen.
Then we've got a Nutella muffin.
It is true that Italians love Nutella,
and they eat it all the time.
Again, when I was a child,
my parents used to hide it.
Mm, sad. [laughs]
And the last item that
we've got is macarons.
We have chocolate macarons,
raspberry macarons,
and pistachios macarons,
or pistacchio, as we do say here.
Oh, the inside is, like,
dangerously green.
They don't taste so much
like pistachio, to be honest.
Desserts, McDonald's US,
we have these exclusives.
Starting down here, the baked apple pie.
The day they stopped frying these
is the day I stopped eating them.
Now they're pulling this with, like,
trying to make it look like
it's a homemade pastry.
It's not. This was just spit out
of an AI oven machine.
Blip, blip, blip. One a second. No human.
I'm the first human hand to touch this.
Also chocolate chip cookies.
They come in orders of
one, three, the trilogy,
or a tote of 13.
One good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today
is the McFlurry machine
was totally working,
and I got this one, the M&M's McFlurry.
We use the mini M&M's,
which are better than regular M&M's,
I don't know why, they just are.
Sundaes, sundaes, sundaes.
Maybe my favorite as a
kid, the caramel sundae.
Mm. Ooh, that's my childhood right there.
And you can get a fudge one as well.
For Italian exclusive desserts,
we have a pistachios McFlurry,
then a Baci Perugina McFlurry.
Baci Perugina are very popular chocolates.
They are made in Perugia, which
is in the center of Italy,
a town in the center.
And here we have a coffee sundae.
It's quite nice that they
actually gave us the espresso
so that we can make our own.
A bit like an affogato, in a way.
The other sundaes are caramel, berries,
another Baci Perugina again,
and the fior di latte,
which is basically the
Italian version of vanilla.
Ooh.
Nice, yeah.
Now on to the cold drink
options, starting down here,
all the soda options
you get here in the US.
Of course, we have way more than Italy.
Starting with Dr Pepper.
Oh, OK there.
So fantastic.
Diet Coke. No.
Ugh.
This completely unnatural-looking thing
is Hi-C Orange Lavaburst.
It's not carbonated,
but it's also not juice.
I can't explain it. It's Hi-C.
You can also get a sweet tea
and an unsweetened iced tea at McDonald's.
What I did feel like getting was this,
the frozen Fanta blue raspberry.
Oh, God, it's so sweet and so syrupy.
Don't drink this, don't
give it to children,
don't have it ever.
They also have a Coke
version, frozen Coke.
Also don't bother.
Lemonade, though.
So, we found out that lemonade in America
is the least different
from lemonade in the UK.
Again, this is not carbonated,
it's not really juice,
it's something different.
I don't know what
lemonade is like in Italy.
Oh, man, it's so tart and so good.
On to coffee drinks,
or should I say cold coffee drinks,
from here to here.
I understand that's not a thing in Italy,
which I think is hilarious.
This giant glass right
here is iced coffee.
You can also get it caramel flavored
or French vanilla flavored.
I went with black, the
ace of spades right here.
Mm.
Oh, man, they do something
with their coffee there.
They do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted.
I mean, I'm sure it's not.
You can also get a iced latte.
This over here is a frappé.
You can get a mocha frappé
or a caramel frappé.
Basically if you're an adult
and you want a milkshake,
you get a frap.
You can also get smoothies at McDonald's.
We have a mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry banana smoothie.
In Italy, we have a few exclusive drinks.
Let's start with the cold options.
We have Lipton iced tea
both in lemon and peach.
Then we have some fruit juices.
We have pear,
ace, which is very popular here in Italy.
It should be very orange.
It's a mix of orange, carrots, and lemon.
Yeah, very orange.
And it's named ace, which is A-C-E,
after the three vitamins
that these fruits,
or vegetables, I guess,
these carrots, contains.
And then we got peach fruit juice.
And here are our McDonald's
hot coffee drinks.
"Coffee," right, Italy?
All right, we get it.
We went a little overboard
with our coffee drinks
here in America, and McDonald's,
of course, is no different.
You can get a caramel macchiato,
a caramel cappuccino.
Why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America, right?
Ah, caramel latte.
You can also get it in vanilla.
Don't.
You can also get a mocha latte.
We have a premium roast coffee.
As I said before, I don't
know what they're doing
at McDonald's, but
I like the coffee.
But you can also get,
finally, a black hot tea.
What is this? The UK?
Ugh.
The hot drinks exclusive to Italy
are obviously the king
of hot drinks, espresso.
Then we've got a Moroccan coffee,
which is not Moroccan in the sense of
it's not Moroccan-style
coffee, but weirdly enough,
and to be honest, I never
really understood this,
it's named after a type
of Moroccan leather
that looks this color.
Honestly, it's like an
espresso with some milk.
And then we got ginseng
coffee and barley coffee,
which technically shouldn't
really be called coffee
because it contains no
coffee, it has just barley,
and this is like an alternative for people
that cannot drink coffee
and they still want to have something
like a little espresso after lunch.
Yeah, it smells very cereally.
I don't know. I'm not a big fan.
And then we got just a
standard latte macchiato.
This is the closest thing
you will get to a latte
that you will find here in Italy,
so it's just a lot of
milk with a bit of coffee
and some foam at the top.
In Italy, a Big Mac will cost
you 6 euros and 10 cents.
In dollars, that's about $6.76.
A Big Mac in the US will cost you $6.29.
That's a 3% price increase
from Italy to the US.
What if you turn that into a combo meal?
In Italy, a small Big Mac
meal with medium fries
and a medium drink will
cost you 8 euros 90,
and that's $9.86.
Does a combo meal make
a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo meal over here
will cost you $11.42.
You can also save some
money if you buy in bulk.
Here in Italy, you can
get a two-person Mac menu,
which includes two Big Macs,
two large portions of fries,
two large Coca-Colas, six nuggets,
for 18 euros.
In the US, we only do Big Mac combo meals,
as mentioned before.
So in order to get the
same order in Italy,
you would have to order two Big Mac meals
plus six nuggets on the side.
It would cost around $36, which
in Italy is about 33 euros.
Price-wise, I think they
are definitely better value
than other fast-food chains.
Well, not to believe Five Guys,
I know that one has a reputation
for being quite expensive,
but I think the burger
is, like, half the price.
For the panzerotti, I think
that was more than 3 euros,
3 euros something, which, honestly,
for, like, three of those as a
side, it is a little bit sad.
But again, I grew up in
the town of panzerotti,
and I used to have, like,
a full one this size
for, like, 2 euros. That was 15 years ago,
so maybe now it would
translate into something
like maybe 5 or 6.
Once upon a time, McDonald's
was the cheaper option.
It was a lot of food
for not a lot of money.
As many people probably
pointed out on social media,
this food is no longer
inexpensive. It's not expensive.
Maybe because of the competition,
maybe because of inflation,
probably because of corporate greed,
McDonald's and most fast food, I find,
is not a good value anymore.
Let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food.
A sandwich that exists in both countries
and is theoretically
identical is the Big Mac.
In the US, a Big Mac
contains 590 calories,
34 grams of total fat, 46 grams of carbs,
and 9 grams of sugar.
How about an Italian Big Mac?
One of those here contains 509 calories.
Of these, there are 26 grams of total fat,
42 grams of carbs, of
which 9 grams are sugars,
and then there are 920
milligrams of sodium.
What if we made it a combo meal?
Starting with the fries,
a medium fry in the US
contains 320 calories,
15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
Italy contains 330 calories,
16 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
of which 0.4 grams are sugars,
and 212 milligrams of sodium.
And let's add the medium
Coke into the mix.
It contains 210 calories, no fat,
56 carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
That's funny there's salt in the soda.
We'll do the same here.
Here's what's inside a
medium Coke in Italy.
It's 168 calories,
zero grams of fat,
42 grams of carbs, 42 grams of sugar,
so it's all sugar,
and zero grams of sodium.
That leaves the total for
the Italian meal at this:
1,007 calories,
42 grams of fat,
125 grams of carbs,
51.4 grams of sugars,
and 1,132 milligrams of sodium.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
Let's talk about ingredients now.
McDonald's Italy shares a
lot of information, actually,
about its ingredients.
That's because the majority
of the items on the menu
are made with 100% Italian products.
The beef, like the one
that's used in the Big Mac,
is sourced from over
15,000 different farms
located in northern Italy
around the regions of
Lombardy, where we are now,
the capital of which is Milan,
and Piedmont.
There are apples from South Tyrol,
which is where speck is made,
just on the border with Austria.
And just to give some recognition
to the southern regions,
because I'm from there,
so no bias at all, we've got some apricots
from the Vesuvio National
Park, so in Campania,
and Sicilian oranges.
And when we talk about
DOP, this red label here,
it's what you are looking for.
It's a label that's used for
a lot of traditional products
around the EU, and that means
that they have to be made
following certain specific standards,
most of the time in a very artisanal way.
That also means that certain
products like Parmesan
cannot be made outside of a specific area.
That has to do with the climate.
So, for example, for cheese,
the main argument is that
it's a raw-milk cheese,
and in raw-milk cheeses, you
do taste what the cows eat.
So obviously, the grass
has a different taste
depending on where you are in the world.
But we do have some
American-sourced ingredients
for McDonald's.
The potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington
at 100 Circles Farm,
which is owned by Bill Gates, apparently.
They grow the potatoes in circles so big
you can see it from space.
The potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 miles per hour,
which is faster than a cheetah.
That's the unit of measurement?
That not-so-secret ingredient
to McDonald's fries
is beef flavoring, which they've
been doing since the 1950s.
You want to see if there's
any differences in the US
and Italy's Big Mac?
These are all the ingredients
in a Big Mac in the US.
Altogether, that's 68 ingredients
that make up a Big Mac.
That's a lot.
28 of those ingredients are in the bun,
which is quite a lot for bread.
The Big Mac sauce also
has a lot of ingredients,
26 altogether, and it seems like we added
a lot of relish to ours, which
bulks out the ingredients.
In Italy, there are 54
ingredients in a Big Mac.
Here they are.
We only have 20 ingredients
in the bun, actually,
because we don't fortify the
flour like you do in the US.
Our Big Mac sauce has 15 ingredients,
which is still nine less
than the US Big Mac, Joe.
Most of the other ingredients are similar,
but we don't have as many colorings
or thickeners as you do in the US.
Some of the ingredients
listed in our US Big Mac sauce
caught our attention, so we
want to explain what they are.
First up, propylene glycol alginate
is derived from brown seaweed
and is a thickener used in foods
to give a smooth natural texture.
Next up we got hydrolyzed corn,
which is a plant protein
from corn or maize
and is used as a flavoring
for its umami taste.
Sodium citrate helps cheese to
melt without becoming greasy.
I did grow up with McDonald's.
I definitely celebrated a
couple birthdays over there.
I had my share of Happy Meals
with lots of little girly toys.
It is definitely considered healthier
than other fast-food chains
because it has been around
for quite some time,
but also, obviously,
because it has Italianized
a lot over the years,
incorporating things like Parmesan
or like traditional cheeses and cold cuts.
So just appealing a little bit more
to the taste of Italians.
I have been to stores
in the US and the UK,
and Italian McDonald's seem, I don't know,
a little bit fancier.
It's everywhere and made burgers and fries
and sodas to go the most
popular meal in the country,
and then how many places followed suit?
With Burger King and
Wendy's and all the like.
And now we got
chicken-sandwich-version ones,
we got fried chicken.
McDonald's McDonald's-ified
the entire country
and the world.
McDonald's is like Nike or Christianity.
It's everywhere!
Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Italy, our drinks come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
We're going to measure the large one
to see how much it actually contains.
There's supposed to be 500 ml.
I think we're getting
close to 600, actually.
140 ml extra.
Burger King in the US.
Our fountain drinks come in four sizes,
value, small, medium, and large,
and the large is 38 fluid ounces,
or 1,120 milliliters.
And now I would like
to measure the largest
and see if that's exactly
how much they gave us.
It's almost exactly 32 fluid ounces.
It's not close to 38 ounces.
Yeah, it says 38 in the bottom here.
Hey, someone who works at Burger King
or someone who works in fast food,
why, why, why, do they say
here's how big the cup is
and then clearly it's not that amount?
What am I missing here?
Every single place does it.
Here in Italy we have
three sizes of fries,
small, medium, and large.
Burger King in the US,
they got four fries sizes.
Over here's the value, then the small,
the medium, and the large.
So, I know that in "Food Wars" history,
Burger King has actually lied to us.
So let's see if they've been
honest with me today in Italy
and measure every single one of them.
The sizes are working now.
The small is actually
smaller than the medium.
I have no proof of this.
I think they saw our US
versus UK Burger King episode,
saw us then call out #frygate2021,
whenever we did that.
#frygate2020!
And they're running
scared, but they still,
trying to pull it over.
A US Whopper.
The Whopper's a fantastic sandwich.
On to the nuggets. In Italy,
they come in three sizes,
a six-piece, nine-piece, and 20-piece.
In the US, our nuggets
come in three sizes,
two if you go into the
restaurant apparently.
You can get the four-piece
or the eight-piece,
but also on Uber Eats,
an exclusive apparently,
you can get a 16-piece.
Both Italy and the US serve onion rings.
In Italy, they come in a eight-piece,
12-piece, and 16-piece.
So, we have four onion-ring sizes,
and I want to point out that for us,
we just do it by cup size.
We're not doing it by
number of onion rings
like they do in Italy.
I have to say, they were very generous
with the onion rings at ours.
I mean, this is the value.
This thing is overflowing
with onion rings.
We have a small, medium, and large.
Here's everything that you can
find at Burger King in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
And here's everything you can find
on the menu at a US Burger
King you can't get in Italy.
Let's start with the burgers.
In Italy, we have the
Italian King collection,
which comprises these two burgers here.
The first one is the Parma
ham and scamorza burger.
Scamorza is a cheese from
south Italy, where I'm from.
So, scamorza, it's a bit
like a mozzarella in a way,
like they come from the
same family of cheeses.
They're made in a similar way,
but scamorza, it's aged for, like, a week,
like, not so much, so it's
like a hard mozzarella.
Let's see how it tastes in a burger.
Nice.
Not a fan of the onions.
I think they overpower a little
bit the taste of the cheese.
Without maybe the patty,
it does seem like a
traditional Italian sandwich.
And then we have the Parmesan burger.
This one has bacon in it.
Apparently when Burger
King launched this burger,
they had to buy something like
500 wheels of Parmigiano-Reggiano,
which is like Parmesan. In
Italy they are the same thing.
So quite a lot of wheels.
I don't know. It feels like a dream
to be in one of those rooms
with 500 wheels of Parmesan.
It feels like, I don't know,
next time you do it, please
call me, Burger King.
I'm coming to collect the cheese.
Better this one than the other one.
This one is a little bit less messy.
The flavors come out individually.
I can taste everything.
Yeah, I like this one.
Always on the Parmesan team.
And then we've got the big king.
This is supposed to be Burger
King's version of the Big Mac.
This one, it's slightly
different to the US
because it has an extra bun in the middle,
and apparently it has a special sauce
that's supposed to taste
like Thousand Island sauce.
Very yellowy.
I never had Thousand Island sauce.
I don't think I've ever seen
it, even in a supermarket.
This is a bit vinegary,
a bit like tartar sauce in a way,
but, mm, I don't know.
I'm not a fan, but I don't
know, maybe there's just, like,
the aftertaste of pickles.
That's also something I don't like.
I know Joe doesn't like them,
so, yeah, there's two of us.
Yes, Claudia dislikes pickles, too!
I'm so happy to hear that.
Claudia has impeccable taste.
So for her to dislike pickles
must mean that I also
have impeccable taste.
So me and Claudia, no-pickle friends.
And then we've got the
bacon burger king 3.0.
It's got three of everything.
It's got three patties, three cheeses,
and actually eight strips of bacon.
It's so heavy.
I mean, I'm going to take this to the gym
to use as a proper weight.
It just looks gross.
It looks like, I don't know, like cement.
I don't know how this is
an exclusive to Italy.
I feel like if I want to indulge,
I'll just have two of something else
that's a little bit less messy.
There are eight strips of bacon, though,
and apparently they are different
in Italy than in the US.
So let's have a look.
And then we've got the Bronx steakhouse.
If you are from the Bronx,
does this look familiar to you?
And then we have the
veggie steakhouse.
Same thing, just with a
veggie party. What is this?
It's like veggie bacon. It's
the first time I see it.
Why is it brown? It looks like a candy.
Tastes like salt and like frying oil.
Not so much like bacon.
Yeah, does give you the feeling
of just having a regular burger.
This is not technically vegetarian
because it's cooked on the
same grill as the meat patty.
I guess this is a burger
for people that eat meat
that want to try a veggie option.
The veggie steakhouse?
That might be a translation error.
I don't know if it could be
a veggie and a steakhouse.
Then we've got the big king XXL,
so bigger size than this one.
This one has got two
patties, four cheeses,
and a special sauce.
Bigger onions as well.
Then we have the plant-based Whopper,
and then we've got the
crazy cheese Whopper.
This one is a delivery exclusive,
apparently for the cheese lovers.
To be honest, as a cheese lover,
what is this amount of cheese?
Just, it's ridiculous.
There was more in any other burger.
It's just for the lovers of, like,
weirdly hanging strips of bacon, maybe.
All right, US burger exclusive options,
starting right here.
Got the bacon cheeseburger.
Look how small this is, by the way.
But as you can see, burger,
got bacon and cheese. Believe it.
Moving on to the Impossible Whopper.
I think that's this one with lettuce. Yep.
Impossible is a brand of plant-based meat
here in the United
States that is just that,
made from plants! No animals were harmed
in the making of this burger, I think.
Something that should be noted,
there is a disclaimer on the
Burger King website that says,
"Our Impossible meat is
cooked on the same broiler
as the regular meat," and
also the mayo on these burgers
does have eggs in it, so, good effort?
Texas double Whopper. Come on, Texas.
Texas is a state in the United States
that does everything bigger,
so of course they have their own Whopper.
It's a double Whopper, double
the size of a regular Whopper.
Look at this. It's got
double the meat. See that?
And jalapeños on here,
although they're kind of
nonexistent, but they're on there.
In the US, we have the
single quarter-pound king.
You saw that earlier. I
absolutely destroyed it.
I threw it away. But also we
have a single Impossible king!
Same thing as the Impossible Whopper!
Why am I talking like this? Look at that.
I mean, you could put this melted cheese
on a piece of shoe leather,
and I wouldn't know the difference.
We also have a bacon Whopper Jr.,
which they didn't give us,
also a big king, which
they did not give us.
I'm certain I ordered it.
Anyway, what we do have is this,
the Rodeo burger, pa-pow.
It's a burger with barbecue
sauce and onion rings.
Man, really generous with the onion rings.
Fun fact about the Rodeo cheeseburger:
It was created to
coincide with the release
of the film "Small Soldiers" in 1998.
Another fun fact: In 1998,
I worked at a movie theater
in Schaumburg, Illinois,
that showed "Small Soldiers."
This was for some reason brought out
in time with that movie.
It was on the dollar
menu, stayed on the menu.
I guess you can see
why. Fun little burger.
And the "Small Soldiers" Chip Hazard,
which is the name of the character,
I didn't even know what his name was,
advertised it by saying,
"You can't handle the Rodeo
burger," which is just like
Jack Nicholson's line
from "A Few Good Men,"
"You can't handle the truth!"
Here are all the chicken items
that you can get at Burger King in Italy,
starting from the Crunchicken.
Fried chicken, mayo, lettuce, and tomato.
You can also get a chicken bacon king,
same thing as the beef one,
with eight strips of bacon.
Next up we have the chicken
royale, with bacon, cheese.
Why is this this shape?
Does this look royal to you?
Maybe it's just easier to eat.
I don't know, but I'm not very intrigued.
A lot of mayo here.
And then we got the
crazy cheese chicken BBQ.
Yeah, there's definitely
barbecue sauce here.
And then we got a
plant-based nugget burger,
which has mayo that is not vegan
because obviously there's eggs in there,
but there are three nuggets in there.
Just quite funny, like a nugget burger.
Here are most of the chicken options
you can get at the US Burger King.
Starting down here, we got
the BK royal crispy chicken.
Every time we do a "Food Wars,"
Burger King's got a bunch
of new chicken sandwiches
because they're trying to
compete with Chick-fil-A,
and if you ask me, they losing.
All right. This looks like
the epitome of "just OK."
We also have a spicy version
of the same sandwich,
the spicy BK royal crispy sandwich.
This one looks crispier.
Much better. Not very spicy.
Good flavor to it. Get that one.
You also have a bacon and Swiss one,
which I think is this one.
All right. I'm going to
get a bite of the bacon
and the Swiss.
Tastes bacony.
Typical to Burger King,
something's popular,
so they make a somewhat inferior version.
You can also get the honey mustard
BK royal crisp chicken blabbity blah.
[groans]
This one also has bacon on it.
The honey mustard's interesting.
We also have a chicken
junior. It's a little guy.
This is basically the
rip-off of the McChicken,
a far more superior chicken sandwich.
Another menu item that was
available over the summer
but may be off the menu now,
certainly wasn't at the BK
we went to here in Burbank,
was the Italian BK royal crispy chicken.
Let's get that picture up on the screen.
This would've been perfect for
"Food Wars," US versus Italy.
Couldn't get my hands on it.
Claudia, what do you think of this?
I don't know. That doesn't
look very Italian to me.
I think if you put crispy chicken,
that automatically makes it not Italian.
Let's talk about wraps.
We thought there were two.
Actually, the grilled
chicken is not there anymore,
so we just got this crispy one.
This wrap looks very sad.
I don't know. I feel
like you could do better
with the actual wrap itself.
Here's what's inside.
I don't know. The wrap is very pale.
BK also has wraps. You can
get pretty much each one
of these chicken sandwiches in wrap form.
I went ahead and got the
spicy BK royal crispy wrap.
I mean, all they're doing is taking --
oh, so it's half a patty.
Not even a full patty.
So you get half a patty and
all this stuff in wrap form.
Like, what's the draw of this?
If you want a wrap,
just go someplace else.
Couple other exclusive
items that we got here.
You can get a taco at Burger King.
I love tacos just as much as the next guy,
but, I mean, look how thin this is.
It looks like the guy sat on
it before he gave it to us.
I'm curious.
I can't be sure, but I think they put
the barbecue sauce in there.
That can't be right. If
they did, that's terrible.
Whatever it is, it's bad. Don't get it.
This right here is the big fish.
Look at this thing. What a nightmare.
They put pickles on it? Guys, come on.
Pickles on a fish sandwich.
I really like the Filet-O-Fish.
I should say that right now.
I think it's a tasty sandwich.
I don't know what they're putting
in the Filet-O-Fish at McDonald's,
probably not a lot of fish,
but I think it's very good.
My favorite thing about the Filet-O-Fish
is their tartar sauce. It
makes and breaks the sandwich.
For them, tartar sauce,
fantastic, so one would assume
that this square fish patty,
correct me I'm wrong, but
no fish is naturally square,
so this highly processed fish patty
is drowning in a white sauce
that should be a tartar sauce,
and we're going to find
out if it's any good.
It's a thicker bun,
so it feels like you're
getting more sandwich.
Yeah, I actually kind of like that.
I don't think it's better tasting
than the Filet-O-Fish, but
it's still pretty good.
Let's see what is in
Italy's king junior meal.
As a main course, you can
either get a four-piece nugget,
a chicken burger, a
hamburger, a cheeseburger,
or a toast, which is what we got today.
And then you also get
fries, a mini Kit Kat,
a drink, and a toy.
Let's see what's inside ours.
Here's our toast.
Tiny fries, cute,
Kit Kat,
the drink obviously,
and a toy.
What is this? It looks like a glass.
It doesn't really look like something
you would give to your child
if you were making their lunch.
It is the plainest thing that you can get,
and usually parents are a little bit wary
of giving sauces and
things that are too rich.
Kids-meal options in the
US, aka the king junior.
You can get either a cheeseburger
or a four-piece nugget.
I think we got the nuggets.
And then your options are either fries,
onion rings, or applesauce.
They have a drink cup that is reusable.
I think it's pretty nice.
And you can also get milk.
See it says "Jr." right there?
And for a toy,
a spoon.
No. The toy, they got nothing.
I don't know if they
forgot to give us a toy,
or maybe they don't have toys?
What?
Oh, you think because
I ordered as an adult,
they're like, "He doesn't want a toy"?
What, all work and no play for the J-man?
Come on, I want a toy!
I think maybe, though,
you think the puzzle's the toy on the bag?
I don't know.
I don't think the spoon's the toy.
So either they forgot the
toy or you don't get one.
We didn't get one.
Exclusive sides we have,
these are two of them.
One thing I want to point
everyone's attention to
are these chicken fries.
That's right, chicken
strips shaped like fries.
Interesting fact about this box,
see how it kind of gets smaller here?
This box was designed specifically
to fit in a car cup holder,
because here in America,
God forbid we stop and eat a meal.
We have to eat and do something else.
I think it's very funny
considering in Italy,
it's like the meal is the event.
Now, it's a chicken fry.
It's more of a marketing
thing to call this a fry,
because it's not a chicken tender,
because tenders come from a
specific part of the chicken.
The fry is more like a chicken finger,
where it's made with whole muscle meat.
They're really durable.
They're really elastic.
Don't you think if you're waving
a piece of chicken like this,
it would've broken off by now?
Look at this! Look at this!
Why is this so like this?
I think they taste fine.
It's just a weird thing
to be on the menu still.
I mean, I don't know
anyone who's getting these.
Mozzarella sticks.
We should've asked Claudia before.
Do mozzarella sticks even exist in Italy?
I want to know. Because here in the US,
you can get these as a four-piece
or an eight-piece with marinara sauce.
These have been sitting for a while,
but of course I'm wondering
what kind of cheese pull
we can get from these mozzarella sticks.
Eh, eh, oh, OK, OK.
Oh, not a bad one. They're just OK.
These are our exclusive
sides here in Italy,
starting from these chili cheese bites.
You can get them in a
six-piece and a nine-piece.
Doesn't look like there's chili
in them. Let's try them out.
They taste a bit too peppery, I think.
I was expecting it just to taste spicy.
Like, they taste like fresh
chilies, which is nice,
but I'm not sure what cheese is this.
Then we've got plant-based
nuggets as a six-piece.
They look a bit green, like there's been,
like there's some filter on them.
They taste actually like nuggets.
I don't know if this is fake chicken
or it's just vegetables,
but they're quite good,
and from the inside they
look like normal ones.
You can then get bacon king
fries with cheddar sauce.
You can also get them
without cheddar sauce.
But here's the ones we've got.
You can also get chicken wings
in a four-piece and a eight-piece.
Here's how they look like.
Just very tiny wings.
When I was little, we used to
go and vacation in this town
in the south of Italy
in a very small village,
and the whole village
on the 15th of August
was celebrating with something
that we call the Alata.
Ala means wing in Italian.
And it was just a big chicken-wings party.
The ones I'm used to, they
were a little bit bigger
and a bit more light colored.
Let's see how this one tastes like.
Ooh, spicy.
It's a bit, yeah, a bit of a spicy sauce.
Yeah, there's a lot of pepper in there.
No, not a fan.
Then you can get two types of toast,
the king toast with Swiss cheese and ham.
This is the same as in the kids menu.
And then you can get it with
bacon and American cheese.
And then we've got griller fries,
or maybe you call these waffle fries.
But we actually have some
packaged chips in Italy
that are sold with this shape.
Perhaps that's why they
went with the fries.
There is a tiny bit of spice
in the aftertaste. Quite nice.
They're doing waffle fries in Italy.
That's a direct rip-off
of the Chick-fil-A fries!
Like, this company is shameless!
If it's popular somewhere
else, Burger King has it.
That's their new slogan.
And then we also have
salads here in Italy.
Technically there are four options,
but we were only able to get two.
So the four options
are just a mixed salad,
crispy chicken, grilled chicken,
and a tuna salad,
which doesn't seem like something
I would like to get at Burger King.
Here we have a mixed salad.
One thing I just, why
are you serving the salad
with a whole tomato?
Who eats this? Like, why?
And we have another one here
which was supposed to be the
grilled chicken, I think,
but it's another one of those mixed salads
with those huge tomatoes.
The salads can also come
with some olive oil.
It was actually given to
us in a little sachet,
but we can't find it.
Sauce talk.
Discurso de la salsa.
Here are all the sauces
that are exclusive to Italy.
Well, technically exclusive
because they're all from Heinz,
so you won't find these in the US.
Heinz makes all the sources here in Italy.
We start from ketchup,
then mayo, barbecue,
sweet and sour sauce, curry mango sauce.
Then we've got spicy tomato salsa,
which, hm, sounds interesting.
And then we've got cream honey mustard.
The last one, which is not
made by Heinz, is Nocciolata.
This is technically not a sauce.
It's a hazelnuts and chocolate spread,
a bit like Nutella.
Yeah, this one, Rigoni di Asiago,
is, some people will
say, the posh Nutella.
It's a very nice and rich spread.
Let's see, mango and curry.
The color I was expecting.
Nice. I'm surprised it's on the menu.
Yeah, it does taste like
curry-inspired sauce
and sweet, so maybe there is mango.
I love the looks of the mango curry.
I definitely want one of those.
Can you please send it to me? Thank you.
Here are pretty much all the
sauces you can get in the US,
since they're not Heinz
products, at least not labeled.
Do you think Burger King
makes their own sauces,
or do you think they're
just going to the source
and putting their own labels on it?
I have no idea. Here we
got a barbecue sauce.
I would love to try, when I go to Europe,
like that's happening anytime soon,
when I go to Europe, I want
to try their barbecue sauce.
Because I feel like what
they think is barbecue
and what we call barbecue
can't be the same.
That's a sweet barbecue sauce.
I'd liken it to a Kansas
City barbecue. Very good.
This is the zesty sauce.
This tastes like a strong
mustard, not honey mustard,
but sweeter than a regular mustard.
Actually, it's closer to a Dijon.
It just says spices.
Doesn't say which ones.
No. It's not bad, just, I don't want that.
Sweet and sour sauce.
Come on! Open like a normal --
imagine if I was driving,
trying to eat my chicken, ah!
I'd be on the opposite
side of the road by now,
crashing into everyone.
I'd be driving on the sidewalk
trying to open this sauce.
All right, sweet and sour, come on.
Buffalo sauce. For those
of you not in America,
Buffalo sauce is named
after Buffalo hot wings.
It's a type of spicy sauce, mm,
you get wings, and now it's on everything,
and no, it does not taste like buffaloes.
It's from Buffalo, New
York, where the sauce was,
the recipe was made or
perfected, I don't know.
It's basically hot wing sauce.
I like Buffalo sauce.
I don't think -- it's
only good on chicken.
On burgers or fries or
dipping, doesn't work.
Last we got ranch.
This country is obsessed with ranch.
I don't know why. It's kind of weird.
But we got everyone in America,
including Burger King, so,
ee!
Ranchy.
And this is Heinz ketchup.
Wait, we have Heinz ketchup,
and they have Heinz ketchup,
so this isn't an exclusive.
But these sauces are.
Biscuits. Here in the US, we
have a specific type of biscuit
that is not a cookie or a
scone, it's its own thing.
Anyway, we can get just about
every breakfast sandwich
at Burger King in biscuit form.
There's the bacon, egg,
and cheese biscuit;
sausage, egg, and cheese biscuit;
smoky maple chicken biscuit;
the ham, egg, and cheese biscuit;
the egg and cheese biscuit;
and the fully loaded biscuit.
I'm not getting all of them.
It's a waste. Here's two.
I got the bacon, egg, and cheese biscuit.
Personally, I think when it
comes to breakfast sandwich,
bacon, egg, and cheese
is the gold standard.
You can maybe do it a different way,
but I think bacon, egg, and cheese
is pretty much the best
breakfast sandwich to get.
Here it is. There's your egg.
There's your bacon and
cheese. There's the biscuit.
It's very dry. I don't
feel like trying it.
And then also the fully
loaded one. This is hilarious.
Want to get this? This has got
a little bit of everything.
Got the egg, got the sausage, got the ham,
got the cheese, and the bacon.
How does this look, Italy? Huh?
Breakfast is served. Let's go!
Not only do we have that in biscuit form,
we have the same exact type
of sandwiches in croissant,
excuse me, Croissan'wich form.
Once again, Italy, your
neighbors to the north,
France, they invented the croissant.
I'm sure all through Europe
you have amazing pastries,
including croissants.
Here in the US, we've
absolutely ruined them
by cutting them in half
and sticking meat and
cheese in the middle.
So here we go. We got the
bacon, egg, and cheese.
Again, the gold standard.
You can also get a ham, egg, and cheese;
egg and cheese; smoky maple
chicken Croissan'wich.
God, that sounds horrible.
Double sausage, egg, and
cheese, I forgot about that.
That's two patties of
sausage, two slices of cheese,
double the diarrhea in the morning.
And of course, the fully
loaded Croissan'wich.
Our cricket buddy is back.
We will try to remove the
cricket audio in post,
but sorry, everyone, we're filming this
in the middle of the woods, apparently.
We have sausage, egg, ham, bacon, cheese,
oh, God.
[cricket chirping]
Cricket, do you want a bite of this?
We also have breakfast burritos.
This here is the Egg-Normous Burrito,
which has bacon, egg, cheese,
a hash brown, and a spicy sauce.
This is for someone who
just wants your first hour
once you punch in at
work to be on the toilet.
So if you're looking to
poop on company time,
maybe grab one of these
on the way to work.
Look at this.
Guys, this is like,
oh, I don't even know what this is like.
I've never seen anything like this.
So of course I have to try it.
Nope.
Gross.
And this next one is a
breakfast burrito junior.
So this one's for kids. Want
to get them started young!
Look what they did!
They put a hash brown at
the beginning and the end.
So you're going to be like,
"Oh, it must be loaded with hash browns.
Mm-mm, one at the entrance
and the exit. Nice try.
Also in the US we're crazy about pancakes,
and we have the pancake platter
and the pancake and sausage platter,
currently unavailable at
the Burbank Burger King.
In Italy, we actually don't have
a breakfast menu at Burger King.
To be honest, I don't think Italians
would like to have what
Joe has in his menu.
Like, a croissant filled
with bacon and eggs
doesn't seem quite right.
I think most of us just
have a sweet breakfast
that usually is just
a pastry and a coffee.
It can be a very calorific pastry
with a lot of Nutella or another filling,
but usually it's always sweet.
Sounds like Claudia is implying
that Italians like something
a little more sweet,
a baked good for breakfast.
So, we do have some of those in the US,
and we do have some of those
obviously at Burger King.
Going on down here, starting off,
we got French toast sticks.
France, as you are aware, is a country
that's right above Italy, and
they have their own toast,
and we have that in stick
form, and this is them.
And it also comes with a dipping syrup.
What's more French than that?
Look at this. Look at this.
I know it's "Food Wars" Italy,
but "Food Wars" France has gotta
be right around the corner.
Any French person watching this right now
is going to have a heart attack.
But yeah, you know, I mean.
You have no idea how sweet this is.
Also, we have these hash brown
bites, these little guys.
Desserts, sweets!
Oh, how we have it in the
US at our Burger King.
You can get a Hershey's sundae pie.
Not Sunday day of the week.
Sundae as in a
ice cream sundae, right?
And I mean, I mean, look at this.
Look at this! Right?
Look at this, how gooey
that is. Ooh! Come on.
Also at Burger King, you can
get soft-serve ice cream.
I didn't get it because
we've been in the studio
for a couple hours and it's very hot,
and it would've melt.
Anyway, you can also get
chocolate chip cookies,
hey!
And a variety of shakes, a vanilla shake,
a chocolate shake, a chocolate Oreo shake,
and this, the Oreo shake.
Every time we do a fast-food place
that has a shake, the
Oreo shake, I get it.
I think that Oreo, as far as
branded cookie snack shakes
you get at a lot of
these fast-food places,
the Oreo is the best one.
Why, do you ask?
Looks like a vanilla and
chocolate shake, right? Wrong.
It isn't vanilla, it's the
Oreo-cream-flavored shake
with Oreo chocolate cookies in it.
Just, I'm telling you,
oh, my God, so good.
Oreo is the best shake, hands down.
Mm!
So, on to the dessert
options here in Italy,
these are the ones that
we were able to get,
but actually there are a bunch of others,
and we're going to put
them all on screen here.
That includes a lot of
ice cream, like sundaes
and milkshakes, but we
were not able to get them.
So this is what we've got today.
We've got Nocciolata pancakes,
and then we've got nutty cheesecake,
crown caramel soufflé.
I think if you call something
lava cake, you will expect,
I mean, I'm sure, like,
half of your customers
will think that you
actually put lava in there.
Yeah, and I was saying earlier,
Nocciolata is actually a very
popular spread here in Italy.
It's a hazelnut and chocolate spread.
I was expecting it to be much thicker.
Let's see.
Quite nice.
Yeah, the pancakes are OK.
It's really delicious.
It tastes much stronger,
much more like hazelnuts
than Nutella does.
Like, these two are competitors.
Approved.
We can also get some milkshakes.
The exclusive ones are
Nesquik, Nescafé, and Oreo.
Drinks in the US Burger
King, we have a lot.
Fountain drinks, for instance.
It's a fountain-drink cup.
I wasn't going to get all these
because it's just super hot,
and it's a pain in the
butt to get the stuff here.
All the other drinks have melted.
I told you I'm wearing this
shirt. It's hot in here!
We have something called frozen drinks.
You can get a frozen Coke
and a frozen wild cherry
and also a frozen blue raspberry,
which is not available.
This was more of a slush consistency
before it melted in this
80-degree studio. What?
Oh, we also got milk. OK.
Anyway, I mean, not bad.
I mean, it's still pretty cold.
But, yeah, usually this is
a lot more icelike, icy.
There's a wild cherry, oh, yeah.
We have coffee drinks. You
can get an iced coffee,
this used to have ice
in it, and a hot coffee.
And, of course, who doesn't like to relax
with a room-temperature fat-free milk?
That'll wash down your burger.
Here are all the drinks
that are exclusive to Italy Burger King,
starting from this very
cute Pago orange juice.
Then we got some tea.
We've got peach and rose, fancy,
and lemon and lemongrass.
We've got Monster Energy,
which has been delivered
in a bit of a funny shape.
And then we've got beer.
You can either get Heineken or Ichnusa,
which is a Sardinian beer.
Some Burger Kings will also
serve a full range of coffees,
espresso coffees, because
that's what coffee means to us.
But because we got our
food and drinks delivered,
we actually were not
able to select coffee,
so we couldn't get any today.
Burger King, in my point of view,
is like fast food's little brother.
It's always trying to
be like the big dogs.
It's always trying to be like McDonald's.
It's always like whatever is good,
Burger King has kind of a
later, crummier version of it.
Now, I will say, the Whopper
is a fantastic sandwich.
I love the Whopper. I get it occasionally.
But everything else on Burger
King's menu, thumbs down,
or at least there's something else
that's better than
whatever they're offering.
You know, Burger King, I only eat there
when it's the ultimate
convenience, which is rare,
because I don't know if a lot of people
outside of the US knew this,
but Burger King's strategy
is to build a location
close to a McDonald's.
Did you know that? So McDonald's
does all this research
about where to position their
restaurants strategically,
you know, traffic patterns,
rent and locations, all that stuff.
McDonald's has a whole
department of people
to figure that out, and
then Burger King's like,
"All right, we'll build
one across the street
from that McDonald's." That's for real!
Like, that's their vibe on everything.
So I don't know what it's
like in other countries,
but in Burger King, you're
just like, "Oh, Burger King."
In Italy, I think Burger King
goes pretty much hand
in hand with McDonald's.
Obviously it's been there
for a little bit less time.
Burger King is quite popular in Italy.
They currently have 232 outlets.
KFC has only got 50
branches here in Italy.
Although they are still behind McDonald's.
That has 630 branches.
Like, some of us have, most of us
have celebrated birthdays at McDonald's.
So obviously we do have some memories
and something that brings us back to it.
I think it's also a
little bit more expensive
compared to McDonald's, and
maybe that's one of the reasons
why people would choose
one instead of the other.
Even though there are some
Italian ingredients in the menu,
Burger King is still
pretty much considered
the American option or, like,
the American fast-food chain,
whereas McDonald's has sort of
got rid of the "American" fast-food chain.
It's just the fast-food
chain, if that makes sense.
They are the first chain that has removed
preservatives and colorants from food,
but there are quite a few
items that we've seen today
that look very shiny and very colorful,
and I would really like to know,
how do you make your cheese
so yellow without colorants?
Like, why? Like, how is that
even possible naturally?
Rivals, I don't know, would you
consider McDonald's a rival?
That's like me saying The Rock's my rival.
Like, yeah, rivals, but, like, come on.
I don't think he's sweating
that I'm out there doing videos as well.
There's no, no one's, I
mean, Wendy's, I guess.
Let's talk about prices.
In Italy, a Whopper is 6 euros, 50 cents,
which is about $7.27.
If you want to make that a
meal with a medium-sized drink
and medium fries, that's
going to cost you 11 euros,
and that's about $12.30.
And in the US, a Whopper
will cost you $6.89,
or 6 euros and 16 eurobytes.
I don't know what the, what? Is it cents?
All right, everyone, relax. It's cents.
There you go, all right.
[beep]
So 6 euros and 16 cents.
Now, that's a 6% decrease in
price. How do you like that?
If you're making a meal
with a medium fries
and medium drink, it'll cost you $12.18,
or 10 euros and 95 eurocents.
So, it actually works out
cheaper to get a Whopper meal
in the US rather than in
Italy, but just by a few cents.
12 bucks? Uh,
I guess I'm used to it,
but come to think of it,
it's a lot more expensive
than what I initially thought.
Yeah, I mean, I don't even
think it's that good of a deal.
It's not, like, too expensive,
but I think almost 13 bucks or whatever,
12-something plus tax for all this
is like, ugh, might as
well get something better.
The prices seem fair.
It is a little bit more
expensive than McDonald's,
but also the burgers
are a little bit bigger,
and it's definitely almost half the price
as, like, a Five Guys.
I think 11 euros is fair,
but if you start getting
close to, like, 15,
that's where I think
I would like to sit down at a restaurant,
and that's probably the
price of a main course,
like a restaurant here in Milan.
So 11 euros was just below,
just below the restaurant line, let's say.
As the Whopper is Burger
King's No. 1 bestselling item,
we thought we would
compare them nutritionally.
In Italy, a Whopper contains 683 calories.
Our US Whopper contains all this.
If you make that a meal
by adding medium fries
and a medium Coke, the total is this.
Making the grand total this.
The most calorific item on the menu here
is the bacon king 3.0,
at 1,342 calories.
That is a lot for a burger.
Our bacon king is also the
most calorific single item
on the menu, at 1,200 calories. Oof.
Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Five Guys in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Burgers in Italy come in two
sizes, little and regular.
Little has one patty, and regular has two.
Our burgers also come in two
sizes, little and regular.
Let's weigh a regular plain
hamburger in both countries
to see who has the bigger burgers.
That's 136 grams.
Nico: 138 grams.
The burger mark is really off-putting.
Any difference might
be down to the patties.
Five Guys actually tells
us that the US patties
should weigh about 94
grams each, or 3.3 ounces,
although this will be the
weight before cooking.
The Five Guys Italy website says
that the patties when uncooked
should weigh 67 grams,
so we're going to see if that's true.
Obviously this has been cooked,
so the meat should have released some fat,
but we're going to find out soon.
This is a Five Guys hot dog.
It looks a little weird
because they slice them down
the middle to cook them.
I really love how these
cook when they're sliced.
Let's measure the length first.
That's about 16.2 centimeters.
I think that's about 15 centimeters.
Yeah, 6 inches.
We don't use inches in Italy.
Now let's weigh the plain hot dog.
That is 144 grams.
We're now going to weigh it.
So, just for reference,
we put mustard, ketchup,
and onions in this hot dog,
so obviously it's going
to be a bit heavier
than the regular one. Let's see.
195 grams.
Our fries come in three sizes
in either plain or Cajun spice.
You can get little, regular, or large.
Our Five Guys fries come in three sizes,
either plain or with Cajun spice.
Little, regular, and large.
According to Five Guys, the
little should weigh 227 grams.
Let's see if that's true.
It's not. It's 82 grams.
This is 82, oh, wait,
yeah, it's 82 grams.
Our little fries should weigh 256 grams.
103 grams.
So, we did ask a Five Guys employee
about how they package their fries.
They scoop the fries
into one of these cups,
put that in the bag, and
then they do another scoop
of fries on top, I think.
So that could be the reason why
some of these weights are off.
There's just, like, fries everywhere.
Don't really know which
fry came from which cup.
It's a mess.
We're supposed to have
1,225 grams altogether,
but right now we're sitting at 870 grams,
including the "extra fries,"
which aren't really extra.
So, our total should
have been 1,220 grams,
but we got 580 grams.
So that's less than half.
Milkshakes in Italy come in one size,
and this is supposed
to be 400 milliliters.
So, this is the vanilla milkshake.
In the US, I believe we only
have one size of milkshake.
So let's see how much we get.
It's actually almost 500.
I'll say it's, like,
480 millimeters.
Something around that.
Here's everything you'll
find at Five Guys in the US
that you won't find in Italy.
Here's everything you'll
find at Five Guys Italy
that you won't find in the US.
The owners of Five Guys like to keep
the restaurants and
the menus all the same,
so there aren't any exclusive
burger options in the US.
This is the Five Guys burger menu.
So, our burger menus are
almost exactly the same.
The only difference is that here
you can order two additional
patties, not just one.
So you end up with a burger
with four patties in it.
I'm not sure you can do that in the US.
Maybe if you ask nicely.
But it's an official feature here.
Since Five Guys is known for
its customizable options,
you probably could order two
extra patties for your burger,
but we'll let you have this one, Claudia.
But seeing as America doesn't have
official exclusive menu items,
Five Guys enthusiasts had to get creative
and make their own in the form
of an unofficial secret menu.
So, this is the patty melt.
It's a grilled cheese sandwich
with an extra patty inside.
It looks kind of good to me.
I love when restaurants do grilled cheeses
with the buns of the burgers.
I think it tastes so good.
I feel like I like this better
than the Five Guys burgers.
It's something about the way
the bread gets all toasty.
It just makes it so much more delicious!
So, next is the artery annihilator.
That's a little ridiculous.
So, we have to put a bacon hot dog
inside of a bacon cheeseburger.
How I'm going to do that, I don't know.
What I think is right is
making it edible in some form,
so I'm just going to break it up a little.
I'm trying to squish it
down because it's not
going to fit into my mouth. OK.
This literally sucks.
Like, don't order this.
There's no reason for you to --
if you want a hot dog and a burger ...
let me swallow this stupid bite of food.
Hold on.
I feel like putting the
hot dog into the burger
doesn't make it taste any better.
It just makes it a lot harder to eat
and a lot less enjoyable of an experience,
so I think this is really not fun or good.
To me, I think this should be at the top.
So let's try.
Double bread?
Yeah, there's a bit of sauce.
All right.
So, here's your Italian version.
Artery annihilator, right?
I don't know. I feel like this is
annihilating my eyesight as well
on top of my arteries if I were to try it.
Too much stuff.
Five Guys is of course famous
for its wide selection of free toppings.
According to Five Guys,
there are over 250,000 ways
to customize your burger.
Now, these aren't exclusive toppings,
but here's what you can get.
The only exclusive
topping we have in America
is A.1. sauce.
In Italy, the toppings are
almost exactly the same
as in the US, but we do
have one exclusive sauce,
which is the HP sauce.
According to chefs at Five Guys,
when customizing your burger,
there's a specific way
it has to be stacked
within their rules.
It should be the bottom bun;
then any wet items, like
grilled onions or mushrooms;
then the first patty;
two slices of cheese;
then another patty;
then dry items like lettuce, tomatoes,
and jalapeños go on top;
and then there's the top
bun to finish it all off.
Let's see if it came in the order
that it's supposed to come in.
So, at the bottom I
see the grilled onions,
I see grilled mushrooms,
and I also see peppers, green peppers.
So it's already out of order
because the jalapeños are on
the bottom for some reason.
I feel like, I don't
know, I feel like this,
if it doesn't affect the taste,
I personally do not care.
But if it's their law in the Five Guys,
then I guess you should
be doing it. I don't know.
All right, so we got the first patty,
the two slices of cheese, another patty,
and then on top we have
the lettuce and tomatoes.
Let's check if the order
is the same here in Italy.
So, yes, we got bottom
bun, onions and mushrooms.
We got a patty, cheese,
we got another patty,
tomatoes, and lettuce at the top.
Good job, Five Guys.
Five Guys also offers sandwich options.
There aren't any exclusive
sandwiches in the US,
but here's what you can get.
So, we have a grilled cheese,
a BLT, and a veggie sandwich.
Veggie sandwich.
Mm-mm.
It's not bad,
it's just a little too
vegetable-heavy for me.
No.
Next is the BLT, which,
if you mess this up ...
Yeah, it tastes like an OK BLT.
It just mostly tastes like bacon.
And then we have the grilled cheese,
which I think will be good
because I already liked the patty melt,
and they're like sisters.
That's a really good grilled cheese.
We do have one exclusive in Italy,
which is a BLT sandwich with cheese,
which is supposed to be this one,
but there's been a bit
of a mix-up in the order,
and the one we got has just
cheese and a lot of bacon.
There aren't any exclusive
Five Guys hot-dog options
in either country, but
here's what you can get.
A hot dog, a bacon dog,
a cheese dog, or a bacon cheese dog.
I've never had a hot
dog with cheese on it,
so I am kind of intrigued.
I will say, though, I am a
fan of the slicing the hot dog
and putting this side on the griddle,
just so everything gets nice and crispy.
I think they do taste better that way.
It's not for me.
Something about the cheese
and the hot dog mixing
together feels wrong,
because I've never had it. It feels weird.
So, this is the bacon and cheese hot dog.
Looks pretty good to me,
but I'm not really familiar with hot dogs.
I think in general in Italy we
don't really have that many.
Definitely burgers are more popular.
Yeah, maybe with some sauce
it would be a bit better.
In the US, we have two
exclusive milkshake options,
the Oreo creme and the Double Stuf,
which I am very excited about.
I love Oreos, and Oreo milkshakes
are objectively the best milkshake.
Let's try the Oreo creme first.
So, this is just the filling
of the Oreos, essentially.
OK, give it a good swirl.
And it is creme and not cream.
That is literally so good.
You're actually drinking
the creme inside of an Oreo.
Next is Double Stuf.
So I assume this has the creme
and also a bunch of Oreo pieces in it.
Oh, my God, this is the best one.
At Five Guys, you can actually add bacon
to any of their milkshake flavors.
This is a vanilla bacon.
I just feel like vanilla seemed like
the easiest thing to pair with the bacon.
I've never tried this
before, but let's see.
It tastes like vanilla and bacon.
I'm just trying to decide mentally
if that's, like, something
I should have eaten.
We thought we had one exclusive
in the milkshake department in Italy.
On their website, it still states
that there is a coffee
milkshake that you can order.
We did order it, but then
when we got to the store
to collect it, turns out
it's been discontinued.
And it's been years they haven't done it.
So please update your website, Five Guys.
We still got a bacon milkshake,
and then weirdly on the website also,
it lets you add every single flavor,
so we got a milkshake
with absolutely everything
that was available.
What's in here? There is
Oreos, bananas, strawberry.
There's so many different
things that just,
in my mind, they don't
really work together.
I think there's just too many things
to even make out what stuff is.
To be honest, it's not too bad.
Now we've got the bacon milkshake.
Mixed in bacon with milk.
It does sound a bit ridiculous.
I'm a bit disappointed, though,
because I don't really
taste the bacon much.
We also have some drink options
you can only get in the US,
Simply lemonade, root beer, and Dr Pepper.
Do Italians like root beer?
That's what I would love to know.
You know what that is. I'm sure they do.
If you're Italian, from
Italy, comment down below
and tell me if you know
what root beer is, one,
and two, do you actually think it's good?
Because here, people love it.
And here are all the drinks
that you can only find in Italy.
We've got Fanta orange, sparkling water,
and then four beers.
So, let's talk about prices now.
In Italy at Five Guys, a cheeseburger
will cost you 13 euros and 45 cents.
Translated to dollars, that is $14.82.
So, for comparison, at
McDonald's you can get
a cheeseburger for 2 euros.
So yeah, for the same price,
13-point-something euros,
you could get six of
these at the other chain.
That's maybe too cheap,
but 13 euros for a burger in tinfoil
just sort of all squished together
still at a fast-food chain,
that's way, way over what I would pay.
In the US, a cheeseburger
will cost you $11.79,
or 10 euros and 70 cents.
That is a 26% decrease in price.
So, Five Guys is doing this thing
where all of their food is
fresh and made to order.
They're trying to kind
of raise the standard
of what fast food could be.
I think that's why their
prices are on the higher end,
although I don't know if
that's fully justified,
because I can say
that I've had better, cheaper burgers.
I think that's allowed.
And to make that a meal,
so with a regular fries and a drink,
that will cost you 23 euros and 20 cents,
which in dollars is $25.57.
Again, so overpriced.
Like, 23 euros for all this,
and I still don't even have a plate.
It's just a lot. A lot.
To make it a meal with regular
fries and a regular drink,
it will cost you $21.47,
or 19 euros and 48 cents.
I ... it's just not making sense to me.
$21 for a fast-food
burger, fries, and drink,
no. Absolutely not.
Let's take a look at some
of the basic ingredients
at a Five Guys Italy.
In Italy, the burger itself,
it's 100% ground beef.
And in the US, a burger actually contains
80/20 USDA ground chuck.
If you want to add cheese
to your burger, though,
here's everything that's in the cheese.
Five Guys cheese in the US contains
all of these ingredients.
Let's look at the bun.
It contains water, salt,
sugar, vegetable shortening,
milk, eggs, bleached bread flour,
yeast, and sesame seeds.
So, in Italy the bun has
a total of 11 ingredients.
That's two more than the US.
The additional ingredients
are calcium carbonate
and spirit vinegar.
The only difference in the hot dogs
is some of the ingredients
to make the pink coloring.
We love dyeing our food here.
The ingredients for the
fries are really simple.
It's just potatoes, refined
peanut oil, and salt.
If you go to a Five Guys,
they have this little board
that tells you where your
potatoes are coming from that day,
and ours came from St. Anthony, Idaho.
And the fries at Five
Guys are very simple.
They are potatoes, peanut oil, and salt.
It's the first thing that
I see something cooked
with peanut oil.
Let's see. Do they taste
like peanuts at all, or?
Actually, they taste quite potatoey.
Like, they taste quite nice.
Yeah, maybe it's the peanut oil after all.
In the US, a cheeseburger
that has a bun, two patties,
two pieces of cheese, and no toppings
comes out to about 984 calories.
The total fat comes out to about 55 grams,
carbs 39 grams,
sugar 8 grams,
and sodium 1,050 milligrams.
In Italy, a regular cheeseburger contains
756 calories,
of which 45 grams are total fat,
40 grams are carbs,
8 grams are sugar,
and 908 milligrams are sodium.
And if you make that a
meal, you can add fries,
and they contain 1,122 calories,
then 66 grams of fat,
120 grams of carbs,
1.7 grams of sugar,
and 716 milligrams of sodium.
Our regular fries are 953 calories,
41 grams of fat,
131 grams of carbs,
4 grams of sugar,
and 962 milligrams of sodium.
And a chocolate milkshake contains
874 calories,
then 39 grams of fat,
121 grams of carbs,
108 grams of sugar,
and 408 milligrams of sodium.
And a chocolate milkshake is 830 calories,
36 grams of fat,
116 grams of carbs,
107 grams of sugar,
and 400 milligrams of sodium.
So, the total for a meal
that includes a cheeseburger,
regular fries, and the milkshake
is 2,752 calories,
of which 150 grams are total fat,
then 281 grams carbs,
118 grams of sugar,
and 2,032 milligrams of sodium.
Bringing the total to 2,767 calories,
132 grams of total fat,
286 grams of carbs,
119 grams of sugar,
and 2,412 milligrams of sodium.
Well, the numbers for the
fries are actually based on
what is stated on the website,
and we got basically half
of what is stated there.
So if you want to make this
a little bit more accurate,
you should halve the
nutrition numbers as well.
Five Guys first opened
in Italy in 2018 in Milan
just behind the Duomo, so
a very touristic location.
And then in 2021 after
a bit of a COVID break,
it opened in Rome, and there are now
another four locations in Milan.
I think, well, starting with Milan,
it's a very smart choice.
Obviously it's the most
international city.
There's a lot of tourists,
like, fashion capital of Italy,
a lot of offices, a lot of
foreigners as well here,
which is maybe the reason
why they opened here.
I know Five Guys is
available in a lot of places,
but something about the branding
and the way the food is presented
feels very East Coast to me.
I think it's because the fries
remind me of boardwalk fries
that you'd get down at the Jersey shore.
It's a little weird because some stuff
has the Five Guys logo on it
and you can tell where it's from.
Other stuff, like the
fries and the burgers,
just come in regular foil,
a regular unmarked cup.
So it's like, it's not a
lot of brand recognition,
at least for me.
I've never even seen a
Five Guys advertisement.
I've never seen a commercial.
I've never gotten an ad.
Once you take this cup away,
you probably wouldn't know
where I got this food from.
Because their burgers are made to order,
it does take longer for
you to get your order.
I've waited, like, at least 10 minutes
for my order at a Five Guys before,
so it's not the fastest fast-food option.
But the food is as fresh as it can be.
It kind of gives me the feeling
of food you'd get at a concession stand
at a local baseball game
at a school or something.
It's definitely got
its own thing going on.
Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pringles in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here are all the exclusive flavors
that you will find in Italy
that you won't get in the US.
Here are all the US Pringles
you're not going to find in Italy.
Starting from paprika.
I've got to say paprika
is something that's
very popular in Spain.
Yeah, it's quite nice, actually.
For those who may not
know what paprika is,
it's actually dried, crushed red pepper.
Very fruity and fresh, in a way.
I know you guys in the US
have a barbecue flavor.
We actually have Texas barbecue.
I don't know, is there
maybe any difference,
or maybe this is just marketing
to appeal to the Italians
because when you say "Texas barbecue" it
feels cooler and we
already know what it is?
I don't know. It's barbecue sauce again.
Is barbecue sauce in Texas
supposed to taste different?
The US actually has dozens
of regional barbecue styles,
including Texas, which has at least four.
So it depends on who you ask,
and I don't know where barbecue started.
Yeah, we also have just barbecue.
How do I describe the flavor? Tangy?
Good, though. I love barbecue.
And then on to the exclusive
train, we've got ketchup.
Hm. I think it's a bit too strong.
I prefer the other ones.
The queen of them all, the pizza flavored.
As I should be, I'm a little
bit worried about those
because as an Italian I'm very
vocal about what pizza is.
I have pretty low expectations for these,
just because everything
pizza flavor to me,
it's, like, a bit of a gimmick.
No.
They just taste like oregano.
I don't know why you guys have this idea
that Italians love oregano so much.
Like, I have so many spices
and herbs in my kitchen,
and guess what's missing.
Oregano.
Weirdly, and maybe I'm going
to be canceled for this,
but the ketchup ones
taste more like pizza,
because they taste more like tomatoes.
Then we've got smoky bacon.
They taste more like the
oil you cook the bacon in.
Not a fan.
You may also be able to
find Emmental Pringles,
but we were not able to track them down.
So, Emmental is a Swiss cheese
made in the German part of Switzerland.
Oh, cheddar cheese. Let's go!
Bursting with flavor.
Get that on screen.
Good.
Ooh, I've never had this
one before, hot honey.
Nope.
Ah, cheddar and sour cream.
Dude, these are always good.
Mm! The chive!
Salt and vinegar.
Got ranch.
Not the best ranch-flavored
chip out there, but not bad.
I think Claudia should try these.
Yo, Claudia, catch!
Gah!
Thanks, Joe.
I've actually never had ranch
sauce or, like, dressing.
I can already see people
sort of walking away from me
the moment I start talking to them
because of the onion.
It's very potent.
No.
I'm seeing flames on both of
these. I'm seeing a grill.
So assumption is these are spicy.
Enchilada adobada.
And the las meras meras habaneras.
Not a lot of heat to
them, but pretty good.
I don't know if that tastes
like an enchilada, but.
Mm!
These are good. They're not like Takis,
but they're in the Taki
space. They're spicy.
They have a Flamin' Hot
Cheeto kind of vibe to it.
Minecraft suspicious stew.
Limited time only. Thank God.
Look, he's got a little
gamer headset on there.
Shameless, Julius Pringle.
Shameless, going after the kids.
I'm surprised. For
something that's clearly
marketed as kids,
this does not have a
very strong flavor to it.
Tastes like a weak sour cream and onion.
Philly cheesesteak.
Check out the best
cheesesteak in Philadelphia
"Food Tours" episode,
staring myself and Harry.
And this is that sandwich in chip form.
I can't imagine one
human being wanting this.
Avoid this.
Oh, smells terrible.
There's also a French fries and ketchup
and everything bagel flavor
we were not able to get for this shoot.
Let's get scorched.
We also have a line of scorchin',
I-N-apostrophe, Pringles.
You can see the steam
coming out of Julius' ears.
This one, he's crying.
He's crying on the Buffalo one.
He's not crying on the other ones. OK.
Something to look forward to.
Start down here with the barbecue.
Come on!
Get hot!
Nope, not scorchin'.
Let's try the cheddar.
I mean, they even have the
temperature thing in the logo.
The thermometer going up.
Not only are they not scorchin',
but also I'm not really
getting any flavor. Cheddar?
Sour cream and onion.
I mean, I love sour cream
and onion chips. [coughs]
Mm.
They taste like sour cream
and onion chips, but,
I mean, I'm getting a little,
like, low-level spice.
This one, as you can see,
Julius Pringle is crying.
Look at this. The chip, the pepper,
and the bottle of hot
sauce are all on fire.
Little bit of heat. Yeah, there it is!
There it is! OK.
I guess look for the tears
if you want spicy Pringles.
Chili and lime.
No.
Instead of scorchin', in Italy,
spicy Pringles are called flame,
and you can find them
as a spicy BBQ flavor
and cheese and chili flavor.
I think I'll be able to have a few
without having to go and drink,
but I think it's manageable.
It's a very manageable spice.
Let's try the cheese and chili now.
This one have two chilies on them,
so they're supposed to
be the mild-ish ones,
whereas these have three.
Ooh!
You're attacked by this cheese
taste, cheese flavoring,
fake-cheese taste.
Not nice.
Also in the US you can
get something called
the Pringles harvest blend.
Four varieties to choose from.
According to the ad copy,
"A deliciously complex tasting experience
unlike one you've ever had."
Barf!
They're potato chips.
Let's embark on this taste
journey unlike any other.
Hang on.
The taste difference between these two
are hardly noticeable.
They definitely look different.
Homestyle ranch.
Also multigrain.
Amazon. This guy drop-kicked
this to my front door.
This is ridiculous!
These are different than
their regular ranch,
and I do like these.
Flavor's not as strong, not
as insane, which I like.
Sweet potatoes, next are sweet potato,
and this is sea salt.
I like that. I like sweet potatoes,
I like maracas, so.
OK, again, the sweet
potato smoky barbecue.
I've definitely experienced this before,
so I want to update that ad copy.
The last exclusives we have
is the lighter side range,
where you can get the lightly salted
and the reduced-fat original.
Could not get them for
the time of filming,
and honestly, I'm glad.
I'm not interested in less
salt or less fat. Forget it.
So, if I were to rank them all, let's see.
OK, worst, pizza.
Didn't like the bacon.
Didn't like this one with the cheese.
Let's put the other spicy one,
just because I'm not so big on spices.
Now I'm going to put the ketchup.
I'm going to put this one here,
and probably the paprika
is the one that I will reach out for.
OK, in no particular order,
my favorites of the day were
the las meras meras habaneras.
Very good. Taking these home.
Cheddar and sour cream.
Always good.
Scorchin' series, a little disappointed
except for the Buffalo.
My guy's crying on there,
so you know that they're scorching.
And I did like the harvest blend ones,
the sweet potato ones.
I sign off on them.
Here's what sucked.
Hot honey. Not hot, very little honey.
The Philly cheesesteak
thing. Yeah, you can't.
And this Minecraft suspicious stew.
I don't, I'm not eating
anything called "suspicious,"
that's just weird.
In Italy, our Pringles come in four sizes.
We've got a 40-gram small size.
You may also be able to find
a pop-and-go 70-grams tube,
but we were not able to track it down.
And then you can also get them
in the 175-grams standard tube.
But if you get the flame
spicy Pringle range,
you only get for the
standard tube 160 grams,
even though the tubes
look exactly the same.
Maybe it's done to protect you.
Sometimes Pringles releases a 3-foot tube,
which always breaks the internet
when it actually comes out.
Sadly, it was not in stores right now,
but it looks like it's just three tubes
stacked on top of one another.
So visually, this is what you will get.
Here in the US, our
Pringles come in five sizes.
Snack stack, then another little one,
the grab-and-go, the original tube,
and the party stack.
That means that the biggest
American size is 10% larger
than the biggest Italian one.
We wanted to find out how
many Pringles are in a tube,
but we didn't really want
to count them one by one.
So we're going to weigh
them and do some maths.
We should be getting 87.5
Pringles in each tube.
Well, the 0.5 is maybe
some, like, crumbles.
The numbers, as we have crunched here
at the "Food Wars" math lab,
is 149 grams total.
And if one chip is 1.9 grams,
that equals
78.4 chips on average per tube.
In Italy, the original
Pringles contain the following.
The original Pringles in
the US contain all of this.
There aren't any major differences,
except for actually coloring
that we do add to our
Pringles here in Italy.
It's annatto. It's made from plants,
and it's totally natural.
I mean, annatto is very dark.
It's a flashy orangey brown.
So it's still very far from this coloring,
but there is a difference with the US.
The longest ingredient list for Pringles
in the US are these,
the scorchin' sour cream and onion,
with 47 ingredients. Good God!
Eleven of these are main ingredients,
and 36 are subingredients.
Now, many of these are flavoring spices
and different dairy products
to create the cream flavor
as well as some colorings
which you may not have heard of before.
Red 40, yellow 5, and yellow 6.
There's new evidence that red 40
is triggering inflammatory bowel disease
because it is disrupting the
way the gut barrier works,
which is harmful and
encourages inflammation.
First it scorches your tongue,
and then it scorches your bowels.
UK manufacturers
were made to remove this
from their products.
However, it can be
legally sold by EU imports
providing it is properly labeled,
"May have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children."
Yellow No. 5, also called tartrazine,
is a type of sodium salt
that, when eaten, it
becomes "sulfanic" acid?
It is this acid that can
cause allergic reactions,
especially in asthmatic
people, and can produce eczema,
hives, and also hyperactivity in children.
Many Nordic countries have banned its use,
but it is approved in the US and UK.
Heads up, Harry.
Yellow No. 6, also called
sunset yellow or E110,
is similar to tartrazine.
And these colors have appeared
in a bunch of flavors,
these specifically.
Obviously Pringles is a very
well-known brand in Italy,
but I think the idea of chips as a thing,
for us, chips are not
really a thing of their own.
They're, like, part of a family of snacks.
In Italy, we tend to have chips
on a snack board with other things,
other items like olives
or tiny pieces of focaccia.
Pringles is not the first brand
that I would reach out to.
It's funny because to me all
these seem quite a big number.
Having to decide between, like,
three, four, five, six, seven,
seven flavors,
and then you got the original, it's a lot.
We just saw the 500
different flavors they have.
Pringles, they're doing
every flavor. Good for them.
But as far as the classics,
the salt and vinegar, the
barbecue, the cheddar,
sour cream and onion,
I feel like Pringles is pretty good at
doing most flavors.
But they also had that
stupid Minecraft flavor,
so I don't know.
I don't know. They are
exclusive to the Italian market,
but they still do seem
adapted to the Italian market,
versus created for the Italian market.
If you wanted something very Italian,
you should have put an olive oil one.
You're really missing an opportunity here.
Just put an olive-oil-flavored chip.
We've talked about this
on "Food Wars" before.
In America, chips and snacks
are all going after each other.
They might be owned by the same company,
and they're just, like, cross-pollinating,
but the chip aisle is just all filled with
these different iterations
of the same kind of idea, so,
I see tube snacks all the time.
I've got actually here some
of the most popular ones.
We've got Fonzies, which are like,
pretty much like chips.
You know, in a way, this is a
very traditional Italian chip.
You also find these.
These are called crostini.
This is like dried bread, you know?
It's a bit like crumbs.
As you say, like crouton.
Especially in the south of
Italy where I'm from, Bari,
we make these all the time.
They're called taralli.
Shape is always the same,
but you always get them
in different flavors.
Actually, my grandma makes them,
and it's, like, the best thing ever.
And they're made with
flour, olive oil, and wine.
So this is the absolute OG Italian snack.
The best.
My grandma's are better, but this is good.
In the US, our original regular tube,
the 5.2-ounce, or the 149-gram,
is currently $2 at Walmart.
In Italy, our original Pringles
in the 175-grams tube
will cost you 2 euros 30.
That's about $2.47.
That means that in Italy we
get a 23% price increase,
although we do get a few more grams.
We wanted to see how much
our biggest portion of Pringles will cost.
For a 48-snack-stack-cup variety pack,
it costs $29.72.
Divide that by 48, and
each snack stack costs
62 cents.
Hey, Claudia, just out of curiosity,
for common Italian snack foods,
how do Pringles compare in price?
Compared to other snacks
that you can get in Italy,
for example, the taralli,
they're actually quite expensive.
And you do get only 175 grams.
Things like these, they're
usually sold at bakeries
for, like, 2, 3 euros per kilo.
So that's quite a lot of difference.
In the US, 100 grams of
original Pringle chips
contain all this.
That's almost half of your recommended
fat intake for the day.
In Italy, a 100-gram
portion of original Pringles
contains the following.
Our version actually contains
more sugar than the US one,
but slightly less fat and sodium.
Across all Pringles flavors for calories,
they're all pretty much the same.
Now, some have 1 gram extra of carbs,
and the sodium is the only thing
that fluctuates between flavors.
In Italy, the flavor with
the most sodium is ketchup.
A 100-gram serving contains
750 milligrams of sodium.
In the US, our saltiest flavor
is the las meras meras habaneras,
with 1,107 milligrams.
That's nearly half of
your daily allowance.
Nico: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Starbucks
in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Our hot drinks in Italy
come in four sizes:
short, tall, grande, and venti.
Our hot drinks come in five sizes,
short, tall, grande, venti, and
the coffee traveler.
Two of these, like grande
and venti, are Italian words.
Venti means 20 in Italian,
and grande just means big.
Let's measure them out to see.
The name translates to 20, but it is not.
In the US, iced coffees
come in four sizes,
tall, grande, venti, and trenta.
Trenta is not available as an option
for their espresso drinks,
but you can get it in stuff like cold brew
or their iced teas.
Our iced coffees come in three sizes,
a tall, grande, and venti.
Let's measure the venti to see
if it actually is 20 ounces.
Eighteen ounces.
So, again, not a true venti.
It's more like a diciotto,
which is 18.
We're also going to weigh
some popular food items from Starbucks.
Let's start with the butter croissant.
So, it's a pretty big difference
to how much Italy's weighs.
It's a lot smaller.
Another popular bakery item
is the blueberry muffin.
Let's see what it weighs.
Here's everything that you'll
find at Starbucks in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything that you'll
find at a Starbucks in the US
that you won't find in Italy.
We know that Starbucks is popular
because of its customization options.
So because of that, we're
only going to look at
the official menus in the US and Italy.
These are the exclusive hot drinks
that you can find at
Starbucks here in Italy,
starting from this tiny cup.
This one is barley coffee.
In Italian we call it caffè d'orzo.
And it's basically an
alternative to espresso
for those people that
cannot really drink coffee.
It has the look of coffee.
I'm not a fan of this.
I think, you know, because I
can drink normal coffee, so,
but if I were not able to,
I think I'll just force myself to like it
just for the pleasure of
still having my espresso.
And then we have a vanilla latte.
It does smell just like a
cappuccino, really, but.
Obviously it's past 11 or so,
so it's past breakfast time anyway,
so cappuccinos are a no-no drink for me.
I'm not so much into drinking milk
after a certain time of the day.
And then we have latte macchiato.
And then we have this one.
This one is a salted
maple and caramel latte.
It just smells like sugar.
It's nice. Yeah, it does taste
like fake, artificial syrup.
And then we've got some teas.
We got Teavana English
breakfast, jasmine pearl,
high-biscus, or ih-biscus, as we say here,
and chamomile.
And you may also be able
to find the Moroccan,
which in Italian just translates
into literally Marocchino.
It's like a tiny cappuccino, in a way.
There's a bit of coffee and
a bit of milk, obviously,
with its own proper ratio.
And it's named weirdly
after a Moroccan leather
that has the same color
that this coffee has.
It's a brown-ish, light brown leather.
That's actually very popular here
in the northern region
in Milan, where we are.
So, here are the hot exclusive
beverages we bought today.
This is the caramel apple spice juice.
The apple crisp oat milk macchiato.
We have a blond vanilla latte,
and this is a royal English breakfast tea.
We also have these exclusive hot drinks.
I feel like I have to try
this caramel apple spice juice
because it looks nothing like juice.
So I'm interested.
I think it's just hot apple cider.
It doesn't taste bad, actually.
That tastes pretty good.
I'm going to try the royal
English breakfast tea
in honor of Harry.
It's not my favorite.
But my preference is iced tea,
not hot tea, so maybe that's why.
And I also like them a lot sweeter.
We have lots of exclusive
cold drinks here in Italy.
We didn't get everything,
but here's what we've got,
starting from a cookies
and cream Frappuccino.
I'm quite surprised this
is exclusive to Italy
because I always associate
cookies and cream with the US.
It has held its shape in the delivery.
To me, this is a bit of a foreign idea
because we just have the
boring chocolate flavor.
Yeah, like chocolate cookies. Nice.
It's like a childhood memory.
Here are all the Fraps that we got.
So, we have the chai cream.
This is the mocha cookie Frap.
This is the apple crisp
Frap, the pumpkin spice Frap,
and the white mocha cream Frap.
I feel very compelled to
try this mocha cookie Frap
because it just looks like a milkshake.
It looks like dessert.
There's literally cookie crumbles in it.
Yeah, it tastes like cold chocolate milk,
specifically Nestlé syrup chocolate milk.
An apple crisp Frappuccino
sounds kind of special to me,
so I really want to taste it.
Kind of tastes like a candle.
I don't like that. Not at all.
But I tried it.
The pumpkin spice Frap
and the apple crisp Frap
are seasonal items,
so you're not going to be
able to find them year-round.
And then we have iced
cold foam cappuccino.
We don't really have a lot of foam here.
It also looks quite dark for a cappuccino,
but maybe that's just
because the foam is gone,
but I don't know. They
keep putting hearts here,
but I'm not really tempted to try this.
And then we have an iced
salted maple and caramel latte.
Does smell a lot like sugar, actually.
Not even like maple. It
actually just smells like sugar.
And you can see the sugar at the top.
I did live in Canada for one year.
Let's see if it does
actually taste like maple.
I don't know if I can advocate
for Canadians out there,
but for what it's worth,
I'm going to try it.
There's no maple in there, definitely no.
It's like sugar.
Not even caramel. Just a lot of sugar.
I feel like a Canadian
would never order this.
But that will be another
episode of "Food Wars."
And then we have iced chai tea oat latte.
Again, quite surprised that
this is exclusive to Italy,
because we're not so big on chai.
I don't know. For some
reason I really like chai
as, like, the tea version,
but I've never really
quite liked it with milk.
So, we have cold brews,
but we also have nitro cold brews,
which are a little bit frothier
and thicker than the regular cold brew.
This is the pumpkin cream cold brew.
This is the cinnamon caramel
cream nitro cold brew.
And here we have the vanilla
sweet cream nitro cold brew.
I already know that I love
the pumpkin cream cold brew.
I kind of want to try
this cinnamon caramel one.
No, not for me.
It's a little weirdly sweet
for something that doesn't
have any milk in it,
I don't think.
Let me try this one.
This one's really good.
I really like the vanilla
sweet cream cold brew.
That just tastes like a
really good foamy coffee.
We then have this one,
the very berry hibiscus Refresher.
And then we have a matcha frappé.
Again, I don't know how
this is specific to Italy
because I think the whole matcha craze
has kind of maybe spared us, in a way.
But there's no other place
where you will find any matcha flavoring,
because I think our
green thing is pistachio.
Like, we just don't have space
for two green things to compete.
Let's give it a try.
I've never actually had
it in a Frappuccino.
Yeah, tastes like matcha.
Just very artificial matcha.
We have a bunch of other iced
coffees that you can get.
Here they all are.
And today we actually
bought the iced flat white.
I've had this before, and
I think I really like it,
but I just want to take a sip again.
Still good, still delicious.
It's a little milky,
but it's really tasty.
We also have several iced teas.
Here we have the pumpkin cream
chai, the matcha lemonade,
a peach green tea, the
London fog iced latte,
an iced passion tea, the frozen
strawberry acai lemonade,
and the frozen mango
dragon fruit lemonade.
Starbucks sells these
Evolution Fresh juices.
This one is orange, apple,
mango, pineapple, and acerola.
That sounds really good.
I've never had matcha
and lemonade together,
so let's taste it.
That's actually not bad.
I thought I was going to hate it.
It's actually pretty good.
Let's try the London fog tea latte.
No! So candle-y!
I feel like I'm going to keep saying that.
Why does everything taste
a little weird today?
I do want to try one of
these frozen Refreshers.
Let's see what this
strawberry acai tastes like.
It's really good. It tastes
like strawberry lemonade.
It's not frozen anymore, but it's tasty.
We then have a bunch of smoothies.
We have this Innocent blue juice,
and the names are actually funny
because they are a play on words here.
This one is called Fa-Blu-Loso.
Then we have a pink juice from Innocent.
This one has another play on words,
it's Rosa A Iosa.
And if you're Italian watching this,
yes, I'm from the south,
because you can tell by the
way we pronounce our O's.
We then have these tiny ones.
This juice is mango,
passion fruit, and apple,
and another one with
strawberry and banana.
Yeah, they look very nice and natural.
We have other cold drinks.
This one is a chinotto,
and they're all from this brand Tomarchio.
I've actually never heard of it,
but it looks like a fancy chinotto to me.
So, chinotto is an Italian
drink made with bergamot.
We normally just have
it from San Pellegrino,
which is a more commercial
brand. Does tastes good.
It's a bit like the Italian
version of Coca-Cola.
My parents' generation, they
were having these, not Coke.
We then have a red orange.
We have sparkling soda
from the same brand,
and we have lemonade,
which looks very nice.
And then we picked up also this.
It's just cold infused water.
In Italian it's called Infuso A Freddo.
And actually we've got more.
Here are the rest of the cold drinks.
Here is the US Only customizable
drink that we created.
This is a caffè vanilla coffee Frap
with half-and-half.
The cup is lined with caramel sauce.
It's got brown sugar syrup, mocha sauce,
and cinnamon dolce sprinkles.
And also I think some cookie crumbles.
There are some mysterious crumbles on top
that I have no idea where they came from
because I didn't ask for
them, but it looks fun.
This is going to give
me the worst tummy ache,
I already know.
That is the sweetest drink
I think I've ever tasted in my life.
It's too much. Absolutely too much.
It is really fun that Starbucks
lets you customize anything,
pretty much anything,
because this would never
have been made otherwise.
There is a lot of food at
Starbucks here in Italy.
Let's start from the savory options.
We've got your dear salmon bagel.
I don't know, does that
have cream cheese in it?
No, it does look like just salmon
and some herbs.
Some sad salad.
Yeah, this is also cooked salmon.
And aren't you big on, like,
smoked salmon over there?
I don't know. Nico, you are in New York.
What do you think from a
New Yorker point of view?
Does that look like a good bagel?
No, it does not.
But maybe it tastes better than it looks.
Now, we have some toasts.
We have ham and cheese.
Looks like an honest toast.
And then we've got the same version,
just with three cheeses.
I'll be curious to know
which cheeses they are,
because they just say three cheeses.
And then we've got
baked focaccia with ham.
Well, OK, first of all,
this is not focaccia.
I mean, I don't know what this is.
It looks great, actually.
Looks very nice and fluffy.
But this is not focaccia,
because it just doesn't have the shape
and it's too fluffy.
It just looks like bread to me.
Yeah, it just looks quite nice, actually.
Like a normal sandwich you would find.
It's quite refreshing
because I don't know
when this is going out,
but, like, the amount of burgers
and things filled with weird sauces
I had to try for this
show is just unbelievable.
And Starbucks, I don't know,
but, like, it looks like
you really made it in Italy.
You're, like, serving actual Italian food.
So thank you.
And here we have some of our
exclusive breakfast items.
This is the Impossible sandwich;
the bacon and Gruyère egg bites;
the bacon sausage egg wrap;
the bacon, Gouda, and egg sandwich;
and here's the berry trio parfait.
Let's take a bite of
the Impossible sandwich.
I've had this before, and I
feel like I mostly like it.
It's just a little bit weird
if you let it sit for too long.
I feel like for a not-real sausage patty,
this actually tastes pretty good.
I've always thought that the egg bites
were some sort of genius move,
even though Starbucks
definitely didn't invent them.
My favorite are the egg white bites.
These don't look edible
anymore, but I'll take a bite.
That's really good, actually.
I think it's just because
I got a mouthful of bacon,
but it tastes really good.
And then we have a bunch of sandwiches.
Here we call sandwiches tramezzini,
but it's just kind of translation.
We have this one with salmon and avocado.
Looks nice, even though the
options outside of the box
look very, like, look delicious.
So I wouldn't go for the boxed one.
We have this one with porchetta,
which is roasted pork from
Rome and the Roman region.
Very, very good.
And, yeah, if you're ever around there,
they also do a lot of nice
festivals, so check it out.
This one has porchetta and mushrooms,
and the last one is this one
with zucchini and eggplants.
We also got salads.
We have chicken and cheese,
what looks like grated Parmesan,
and then we got tuna and feta
with croutons and olives again.
This is all you need for a salad.
The only Caesar we know
here is Julius Caesar.
I know that's bad, but actually it's true.
It's just very, very
cliché, but it's true.
We don't like Caesar salad.
And then we've got this
one, it's called pincho,
with cured ham, artichoke
sauce, and mozzarella.
OK, interesting shape. It looks funny.
I don't really know what a pincho is.
It may be something from
another Italian region.
I'm not so familiar with it actually.
To be honest, this
artichoke is a bit of a joke
because there is not a lot of it.
Let's try it out and see.
That artichoke actually
tastes quite natural,
so very nice.
Yeah, it's not flavoring.
Yeah, I like this one.
We then have some stuffed croissants
because here we're not French,
so we're not scared of
putting things in croissants,
like our friends across the border.
So this, they're quite similar.
This one has cured ham and
scamorza, it looks like.
A little salad thing.
I honestly, I don't really like it.
Doesn't taste like much,
and it just ruins everything visually.
Next croissant we have, I
think it's the same cheese
just with cooked ham instead.
In Italy we actually do eat
a lot of savory croissants.
Sorry, French people.
We usually eat them as
tiny bites in an aperitif.
They serve them. They're
really, really this size.
They're very tiny.
We also have this one,
which is supposed to be a focaccia
with a plant-based schnitzel.
I mean, honestly, this is not focaccia.
I mean, quite clearly there's
been some mistake in the menu
because it's just a sandwich,
and I don't know, why
do plant-based things
always have very sad buns like this?
Why don't you use this one?
This looks much nicer.
This is just very sad and plain.
We do have some snacks as well.
We have some mixed fruits and nuts,
we have roasted and salted mixed nuts,
and then we have cheese snacks.
OK, this looks like it's a thing,
because McDonald's also
has those tiny Parmesans,
those tiny Parmesan snacks,
and Starbucks seems to be following suit
and just giving you some cheese snacks.
It just says it's a semi-hard cheese.
And it's only made with
three ingredients. Nice.
You know, milk, salt, and rennet.
OK, no, I'm a bit disappointed.
I was expecting actual cheese,
like tiny bits of cheese.
This is like, it's like a chip.
Yeah, they're cheesy. They're
not too bad, actually.
Moving on to our more lunchy options.
This is the grilled cheese on sourdough.
The tomato mozzarella
sandwich on focaccia.
They also offer a ham
and Swiss on a baguette
and a Turkey provolone pesto on ciabatta
that we did not get.
I want to take a bite
of this grilled cheese.
The bread actually looks pretty good.
There's not going to be a cheese pull.
It's going to crack in half if I do that.
It's literally so solid
from sitting here all day.
[crew laughing]
OK, wait, it looks like
there's no cheese even in this.
That's so weird.
It must be a lighter cheese.
I've had way better grilled cheese,
but this bread's actually pretty tasty.
This sandwich seems
inspired by Italian flavors,
so I'm very shocked that
it's not on the Italian menu.
That is one sad-looking sandwich.
I'm going to take a bite from the middle.
Don't be mad. It's just
that all the filling
has moved to the center of the bread.
It's not bad. It's not great,
but it's not a bad sandwich.
It mostly tastes like pesto.
We also have a variety of protein boxes.
Here we have the PB&J protein box.
This used to be my lunch every single day
when I was in college.
Starbucks in Italy has
a lot of bakery options.
This I'm very excited about
because I think we do actually
associate Starbucks with
a breakfast café, in a way.
Starting from a maple and pecan braid.
Then we have a cinnamon swirl.
Yeah, it looks nice and fluffy.
And then we've got the saddest,
saddest-looking croissant ever.
This is the vegan one.
It's just a very unpleasant brown.
Is this what the lack of butter makes?
Like, just something very brown?
It doesn't feel that great, and inside,
it just actually ...
it cuts a little bit like a bread,
in a way.
Right, bread's vegan, yeah.
So here's some bread in
the shape of a croissant.
And then we've got another croissant.
This one is multigrain and honey.
And then we've got a plain one.
Very good lamination, actually, Starbucks.
Look, there's a lot, a lot of layers.
Actually, Starbucks
called these croissants
"French croissants" in Italian as well.
And they actually do look quite different
compared to the Italian
croissants that I'm used to.
Italian croissants,
they're not made of layers
of dough and butter.
Let's see.
A plain one, I will have it
only if it's laminated this way.
I think the Italian one is
just really meant to be filled,
so I'm curious to see how the
others actually look and feel,
just because they are
still the French ones,
but they are filled.
So, we've got this one
here with apricot jam.
Let's check it out.
Yeah, lots of jam.
Looks quite nice.
And then we have the
green thing here in Italy
that is not matcha.
It's pistachio.
Tastes like a nutty spread.
Quite a nice spread.
There's not a lot of it, though.
And final one, we've got the custard.
This also looks quite nice.
Just want to see how much
custard there is in here.
There's a lot. It's a bit eggy as well,
which is what I would
look for in a custard.
Not too lemony, just a hint.
And a bit of vanilla.
And apparently you can also
get a hazelnut croissant,
but we were not able to get it.
And then we have a double-chocolate cookie
and a hazelnut doughnut.
Yeah, we're starting to
enter foreign territory here.
Maybe a bit sad compared
to what's coming after,
which are these mini doughnuts.
Quite cute and colorful.
And then we have some brownies.
We have a caramel crumble brownie,
and then we have a
triple-chocolate brownie.
I actually quite like brownies.
It's one of those sort
of foreign cakes that
I'm kind of very used to,
and I don't mind having it.
Let's see if we do it well here in Italy.
This is like the ones I'm
used to that I've had.
And then we have this one.
It's a raspberry and coconut loaf cake.
It does look a bit like
a typical Italian cake.
I had no idea that this type of cakes
were called loaf cakes,
but seems quite accurate.
Not quite convinced about
the stuff at the top.
It just doesn't seem necessary.
I would've put it inside
just to flavor the dough
rather than just put it at the top.
And then we have a strawberry cheesecake.
Then you may also be
able to find apple pie;
apricot-filled rings;
custard and raisin swirl;
then a vanilla and chocolate muffin
that's also available in triple chocolate,
brownie, and orange;
mini chocolate muffins;
carrot cake, that can also be
red velvet and chocolate cake;
and a milk chocolate gold coin.
The US also has a lot of baked goods.
We have a couple of the
iconic Starbucks cake pops.
I want to take a bite of
this cookies and cream one.
That's so good.
This is the blueberry scone,
the everything bagel,
the petite vanilla scone, the coffee cake,
even though it looks
like someone sat on it.
It looks a little smooshed,
but it's very good.
The incredible, incomparable lemon loaf.
It's delicious.
The glazed doughnut.
I did say that Italy's
bagel didn't look that good,
not that ours looks any better,
but I just want to taste
the everything bagel
to see what the flavor is giving.
It's, like, mediocre.
It's not that good on flavor,
and it's not a great texture.
I would only reach for a
Starbucks bagel if I was, like,
going on a flight or something
and this was just my only option.
I don't think that I
would ever purchase it
with a million other good
bagel options around me.
So, the pumpkin loaf
and the pumpkin cream cheese
muffin are seasonal exclusives
along with the baked apple croissant,
which was not available today.
I feel like people are
buying them like crazy.
They're really good.
And if you want the little snacks,
there are also these options.
We've got yogurt with wildflower honey
and yogurt with berries and jam.
Then we've got some fruits.
You can also get pineapple,
and then we've got just a fruit salad.
And finally we've got this
thing, the cookie straw.
So, is this how you're
supposed to have it?
This feels like something
a child would have.
It's like I'm alone at
home and I'm, like, 12.
I'm having a very calorific
drink with a weird straw.
Yeah, weird.
I actually don't mind the straw per se,
but just the idea seems so ridiculous.
We also got a few iconic
Starbucks checkout snacks.
So, this is the marshmallow dream bar,
we have the madeleines,
and we also have the
vanilla almond biscotti.
I see these at every
single Starbucks I go to,
and I'm always tempted to buy one.
I kind of want to try these madeleines.
I don't think I've ever
had a madeleine before.
That's pretty good!
It kind of tastes like
a cakey sugar cookie.
I don't know if it's
supposed to taste like that,
but it does taste like that.
You may also know Starbucks
for the Starbucks Reserve roasteries
that are very much present in the US.
You can also find them in other countries,
and actually there's one
here in Italy too in Milan
that opened in 2018.
And the roasteries are famous for having
different types of coffee
that have the rarest coffee
that you can find at Starbucks.
They offer experiences at these roasteries
where they demonstrate different
ways to make the coffee
through blending, brewing, and infusions,
and they also have wine, beers, cocktails,
some of which include coffee.
They have a lot of food options too.
Each roastery is a little
different in its architecture,
so it's really interesting
just to have a look around.
Unfortunately we were not able
to visit the roastery in this trip,
but we actually went in 2018,
so we're going to play
some footage of our visit.
I was there.
We took a visit to one of the roasteries
here in New York City.
It was really cool to see
how they make these different drinks,
and everything in there is so fancy
compared to a regular Starbucks.
These are the drinks exclusive
to the New York roastery
that we wanted to try.
Let's start with the
hazelnut bianco latte.
I love hazelnut, so.
It's really good.
It's really, really, really good!
I feel like it tastes better
than any other Starbucks coffee I've had.
Let's try the
whiskey-barrel-aged cold brew.
This is intriguing to me.
I hate whiskey,
but there's no real whiskey in this.
OK, wait, it tastes like
there is whiskey in it,
but there isn't!
I made sure to say alcohol-free.
I think from what I'm understanding is
that they might age this
in the whiskey barrels
once the whiskey is
removed from those barrels,
but it still tastes very strong.
It's spirit-free, but
the spirits are lurking.
You can still taste it.
This was actually invented in Italy
and then, yeah, launched again,
recreated at the roastery.
This is the oleato caffè latte,
and oleato just literally means oiled,
and it's just a caffè latte
with a shot of olive oil.
Apparently this is the CEO of Starbucks
that traveled to Italy, to Sicily,
and just saw some people having
shots of olive oil in coffee
and thought it would be a good idea
to roll this out internationally.
And for some reason thought that
all Italians were actually doing it.
I don't know, it's the
first time I hear it.
Like, I would be quite happy
to have a shot of olive oil
for just energy,
but I don't know if I
would like it in my coffee.
That seems like a bit too much.
It's like, "Oh, what are two things
Italians are associated with?
Olive oil and coffee.
Let's just put them all
together and make it a drink."
It's green!
And obviously the oil is
floating on the coffee.
Well, so the idea is that
they should emulsify,
but it's been sitting here for a bit
because we've been doing all the filming,
so perhaps that's why they separated.
It just smells like coffee.
Let's try it out.
I don't taste much the
olive oil, which is OK.
It leaves you a different
feeling on the lips,
like the same feeling that you get
when you bite into a very oily thing.
This is the moment that I've
been dreading this entire day.
The oleato caffè lattes.
These are basically lattes
with a bunch of olive oil in them.
I don't know whose idea this was.
It doesn't sound like a good idea to me,
but let's see which one is
better, iced or not iced.
It's not bad.
I can definitely taste
that there's oil in this,
but it's not aggressively
oily in my mouth,
which is what I was really dreading.
It's really not terrible.
I think it's the oat milk that's helping
cover up some of what's happening.
This looks terrible.
The iced latte has completely separated,
so the top is just a layer of olive oil,
which means I'm going to get a mouthful
of olive oil upon first sip.
It just tastes like a
mouthful of olive oil.
Let me mix it with a straw
and see if that helps.
To be clear, this didn't look like this
when they first gave it to us.
It's just been sitting around for a while.
It tastes better but still
mostly tastes like olive oil.
I think if I had to get an oleato again,
I would only get it hot,
just because it covers up
all the olive oil flavor,
which kind of defeats the
purpose of getting one of these.
But they're not terrible.
It's quite hard actually for me to think
that Starbucks is actually
competing with the cafés
that you can find here,
just because the offer
is very, very different.
Like, it's the only place
where you can find drinks
this size, this elaborate,
and with this much cream and milk
and syrups and all this stuff.
I would say in general Starbucks
is definitely huge here.
You can find them everywhere.
I feel like you're either a Dunkin' person
or you're a Starbucks person.
And it's very common for
a chain like Starbucks
to be somebody's everyday coffee shop.
I will say if you live in a major city
with a lot of other options,
a lot of different coffee shops,
you might not head to
Starbucks all the time,
but it is one of the more
popular coffee options
in places like suburbs.
It's hard to say that it's popular
because it is not really
present everywhere.
Obviously it is in Milan,
Rome, and the big cities,
but you won't find it in a village.
What we do, I'm from a
medium-sized town in Italy,
but in the evening I'll
go out to a small town.
You know, during the day I'll go out
for a day trip in a small town.
I won't live there, but
I will hang around there.
That's where you don't find the chains,
and I think that is what
still makes Starbucks
perceived as something a bit foreign
because you still don't
see it in these tiny towns
and you still see the local café.
It's just in general the idea of chains
doesn't really resonate well.
In terms of the actual
coffees, like the long coffees,
I don't know actually if
they get lots of orders
from Italians.
I think you either just, I
would either go personally
just for a simple espresso
or for the elaborate things
because they are a bit
like an ice cream to me.
Treat yourself, but also,
like, if I see you drinking
that cookie crumble mocha
Frap at 9 in the morning,
I'm gonna slap it out of your hand.
Grow up, please!
Just the culture of, like,
the big drink to take away,
to drink on the go, drink in your car,
that's just not how
things work around here.
People really love the
Starbucks seasonal menus.
I think every year when fall
or Christmastime rolls around,
everyone gets super excited
to see what new stuff is on the menu,
what old stuff is coming back.
I mean, yeah, speaking of the food,
I think they've done a very good job
sort of adapting to the Italian flavors.
The drinks are a little bit different.
There are some things,
like cookies and cream,
that are just not Italian.
We all know that Starbucks
is a big American chain,
and I think they obviously
want to keep a part of that
because Italians are
curious about it as well.
Unfortunately, Starbucks
does not list ingredients
on its website.
We did try to get in contact,
but we're still waiting for a reply.
The US, however, does provide
all of the ingredients
for their full menu.
We thought it would be interesting
to see what's in the oleato range,
since both US and Italy
have this available.
The oleato caffè latte with
oat milk contains oat milk,
which is just water and oats, canola oil,
dipotassium phosphate, calcium carbonate,
tricalcium phosphate, sea
salt, dicalcium phosphate,
riboflavin, vitamin A,
vitamin D2, vitamin B12,
brewed espresso, which
is just water and coffee,
and extra-virgin olive oil.
The exciting thing about
this drink is the addition
of extra-virgin olive oil,
which is mostly associated
with a Mediterranean diet.
It does ramp up the calories
compared to a normal latte,
which with 2% milk is 190 calories.
But there's been a lot of
research surrounding the benefits
of extra-virgin olive oil,
particularly around preventing diseases
and decreasing cholesterol.
Plus the oleato latte has
been fortified with vitamins,
so sounds pretty good to me,
even though I'd never order this again.
In the US, a venti caramel
Frappuccino is $6.75,
or 6 euro and 37 cents.
Keep in mind, that's a New York price.
The prices might vary slightly
depending on what state you're in.
In Italy, a caramel Frappuccino
is 5 euros 70 cents.
That translates to roughly $6.19,
so it actually works out
cheaper here in Italy.
In the US, a venti cappuccino is $6.25,
or 5 euro and 90 cents.
In Italy, a venti
cappuccino is 3 euros 40.
In dollars, that translates into $3.69.
To be honest, they're
kind of fair judging by
how big the things are.
Coffee's always quite
cheap actually, in Italy.
It's usually around 1 euro.
Lately has gone up a little bit,
but, like, if you pay 1.50,
it's already very expensive.
Make note of the fun Colonel
Sanders doing a cartwheel.
Wasn't this guy, like, 70
when he started Kentucky Fried Chicken?
There's no way.
If he's doing that, it's against his will.
Moments before the ambulance was called.